Hello everybody, today we are rerunning the third episode in season five, Business Ethics. This is the episode where Michael and Holly have lunch at Cooper's Seafood. Yes, and we went into our mailbag and found this fun catch from Seth H. and several others. Seth wrote in and said this, I have a continuity catch from this episode. At Cooper's, Holly says she's from Des Moines. But when she and Michael get engaged in a later season, she needs to move quote, home to Boulder, Colorado. So where is Holly really from?
大家好，今天我们将重播第五季的第三集《商业道德》。这一集讲的是迈克尔和霍莉在库珀海鲜餐厅吃午餐。是的，我们在信箱里收到了赛斯·H.和其他几个人发来的这个有趣的细节。赛斯写信说：我在这一集里发现了一个关于连贯性的细节。在库珀餐厅，霍莉说她来自得梅因。但当她和迈克尔在后来的某一季订婚时，她需要“回”科罗拉多州的博尔德。所以霍莉到底来自哪里？
Jenna, I was curious about this and I wondered if the show Bible said anything more about where Holly is from. Well, you know I love any chance to get out the show Bible. I know you do. So I checked it and it said Holly is, quote, originally from Des Moines. There is nothing about Colorado in the whole show Bible for Holly. That's correct.
珍娜，我对这个很好奇，我想知道剧本圣经（Show Bible）里有没有提到霍莉到底是哪里人。哦，你知道我一有机会就喜欢翻出剧本圣经。我知道你喜欢。所以我查了一下，上面写着霍莉“原本来自得梅因”。整部剧的剧本圣经里关于霍莉的背景，完全没有提到科罗拉多。确实如此。
However, the show Bible stops at the end of season five. Really? Mm-hmm. Now this was the show Bible that they gave me in season nine when I became a producer. So they clearly would still reference it, but it had not been updated since the end of season five. And I was wondering, could this be why there are so many continuity issues in later seasons? Yeah, no one was updating the show Bible. Not anymore. Now I do want to say that where you are quote from or what you consider your hometown can be two different places. That's true.
然而，剧本圣经在第五季结束时就停止更新了。真的吗？嗯哼。这是他们在第九季我成为制片人时给我的剧本圣经。所以他们显然还会参考它，但自从第五季结束以来，它就没有更新过了。我在想，这会不会就是为什么在后面的剧季里会有那么多连贯性问题的原因？是的，没有人更新剧本圣经了。不再更新了。不过我想说的是，你所谓的“来自”哪里，或者你认为你的家乡是哪里，可能是两个不同的地方。确实如此。
For me, I was born in Fort Wayne, Indiana, but I grew up in St. Louis, Missouri. So I would probably say that I'm from St. Louis. I get that. I consider st. Louis my hometown But it could still be accurate for me to say oh, I'm from Fort Wayne, Indiana, but my hometown was st. Louis I don't know. So maybe Holly was born in Des Moines, but she grew up in Boulder I don't know. I get it when people ask me where you're from I sometimes am perplexed because I'm like well, I was born in Lafayette, Louisiana me where you're from. I sometimes am perplexed because I'm like, well, I was born in Lafayette, Louisiana, but then I lived 12 years from 2 to 14 in Jakarta, Indonesia. Then we moved
对我来说，我出生在印第安纳州的韦恩堡，但我是在密苏里州的圣路易斯长大的。所以我可能会说我来自圣路易斯。我懂。我把圣路易斯当作我的家乡。但我说“哦，我来自印第安纳州的韦恩堡，但我的家乡是圣路易斯”其实也算准确。我不知道。所以也许霍莉出生在得梅因，但她在博尔德长大。我不知道。我懂，当别人问我你是哪里人时，有时我也会感到困惑，因为我会想，嗯，我出生在路易斯安那州的拉斐特。问我是哪里人。有时我也会感到困惑，因为我会想，嗯，我出生在路易斯安那州的拉斐特，但我2岁到14岁的12年里住在印度尼西亚的雅加达。然后我们搬到了
to Texas and my parents are from there, but then I moved to New York. Then I moved to Los Angeles. I don't know. Yeah. I mean, I've now lived in LA longer than I ever lived in St. Louis. So it's like, what is my home town? Is this my hometown now? I don't know. I don't know. I still think of it as St. Louis. I know, and then I still say when I go to see, you know, my mom, I'm going home. Right, right.
德克萨斯州，我父母是那里的人，后来我搬到了纽约。然后我搬到了洛杉矶。我不知道。是的。我的意思是，我现在住在洛杉矶的时间比我在圣路易斯住的时间还要长。所以这就像，什么是我的家乡？这里现在是我的家乡吗？我不知道。我不知道。我还是认为圣路易斯是我的家乡。我知道，而且当我去看望，你知道，我妈妈的时候，我还是会说我要回家了。对，对。
Yeah. All right, well, before we get to our rerun of Business Ethics, a little office ladies update to say that we have been working on our upcoming episodes. We are super excited to announce that in addition to continuing the rewatch, we also have an to announce that in addition to continuing the rewatch, we also have an interview with Katherine Tate coming up. It was so good.
好的，在我们重播《商业道德》之前，先播报一点“办公室女士”的近况，我们一直在筹备接下来的节目。我们非常兴奋地宣布，除了继续重播剧集之外，我们还有一个。要宣布的是，除了继续重播剧集，我们还将对凯瑟琳·泰特进行一次采访。真的太棒了。
She was in studio with us and it is funny and she is delightful and she had so many memories we can't wait for you to hear it. Oh, I loved her. All right. Now our rerun of Business Ethics, which includes an interview with another amazing woman, Amy Ryan. Enjoy. I'm Jenna Fisher.
她和我们一起在录音室里，这期节目非常搞笑，她本人也非常讨人喜欢，她有那么多的回忆，我们迫不及待想让你们听到。哦，我太喜欢她了。好的。现在是我们的《商业道德》重播，其中包含对另一位杰出女性艾米·瑞安的采访。请欣赏。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office.
我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们为你带来独家的《办公室》重播播客。每周，我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身处其中的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。我们接下来将对办公室进行一系列的采访。
And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. And we're going to be doing a series of interviews with the office. podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes
我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。我们将对办公室进行一系列的采访。专为你们制作的播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并送上独家的幕后
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hi everyone. Hey guys. What's up, Ange? What's up with you and your cute pants? Thank you for saying that. I noticed them right away.
故事，只有当时身在其中的两个人才会知道。我们是“办公室女士”。大家好。嘿，伙计们。安吉，怎么了？你和你的可爱裤子怎么回事？谢谢你这么说。我一眼就注意到了。
Here's the thing, I hit a wall with sweatpants. What? I know. Guys, one of the reasons we started this podcast was because I wanted a job I could do in sweatpants. We talked about that a lot early on. Yeah. Well, I counted after 409 days of wearing sweatpants. I mean, not every single day, but for the most part for the last 409 days, I would get out of bed and put on sweatpants. I actually had several pairs of pants that were made of the same material as my sheets. Like a jersey? They're a bamboo.
事情是这样的，我穿运动裤已经穿到头了。什么？我知道。伙计们，我们创办这个播客的原因之一，就是因为我想要一份可以穿着运动裤去上班的工作。我们早期经常讨论这个。是的。嗯，我数了一下，在连续409天穿着运动裤之后。我是说，不是每天都这样，但在过去的409天里，基本上我一起床就会穿上运动裤。我甚至有好几条裤子，材质跟我床单的布料一模一样。像针织面料吗？它们是竹纤维的。
Made by the same company that makes my sheets. Listen, if I can have pants made by people that make bedding. That's what I thought. It's like I'm just wearing my bed around all day. I thought I'd hit the jackpot. OK, so after 409 days of this, I hit a wall. And I was like, I need to wear pants, actual pants. So I went out and I bought a pair of pants, Angela.
由生产我床单的那家公司制造。听着，如果我能穿由制造床上用品的人做的裤子。我也是这么想的。这就像我一整天都把我的床穿在身上一样。我觉得我中了大奖。好吧，在经历了409天的这种生活后，我达到了极限。我就想，我需要穿裤子，真正的裤子。所以我出门买了一条裤子，安吉拉。
I'm going to stand up. I'm going to show you. I'm going to describe them to you. I'm going to take a picture. They kind of look like camouflage, but like very sassy cargo kind of pants. Yeah, that's what I was going for. Sassy cargo? Yeah, I love a sassy cargo. Okay. All right. So here's the thing. I think I'm so used to wearing sweatpants. I'm in the dressing room and I don't know which size of pants to buy. Because you've been wearing the baggy britches.
我要站起来。我要给你看看。我要向你描述一下。我要拍张照片。它们看起来有点像迷彩服，但非常时髦，有点像工装裤。是的，这就是我的目标。时髦工装裤？对，我很喜欢时髦工装裤。好的。好吧。事情是这样的。我想我对穿运动裤太习惯了。我在试衣间里，不知道该买什么尺寸的裤子。因为你一直穿着肥大的裤子。
That's right. I went back and forth and back and forth and I went with the bigger size. And now I've been wearing them for what? I don't know, an hour. Now they're all stretched out. They're too big. And look what happens.
没错。我拿不定主意，换来换去，最后选了尺码大一点的。现在我穿了多久了？我不知道，一个小时。现在它们全撑大了。太大了。你看发生了什么。
Now they're falling down and I've got long crotch. Long crotch lady. Oh I see it. You have long crotch. Gals, you know what we're talking about. What do I do? When like the seam of your pants is like halfway between your thigh and your knees, that's long crotch.
现在它们在往下掉，我的裤裆变得好长。长裆大妈。哦，我看到了。你的裤裆好长。姑娘们，你们懂我在说什么。我该怎么办？当你的裤裆缝隙夹在你的大腿和膝盖之间的一半时，那就是长裆。
Yeah. So what do I do? I've worn them. I can't take them back and get the smaller size. I think I could get someone to alter it in the back. Oh, my mom could do that in two seconds. I know. And the thing is, is I just, I'm trying to re-enter.
是的。那我该怎么办？我都穿过它们了。我不能退货换小码的。我想我可以找人在后面改一下。哦，我妈妈两秒钟就能搞定。我知道。问题是，我只是，我正在试图重新融入。
You're trying to re-enter the world. You know, I like the sassy cargo minus the long crotch. What are we doing today? All right, let me tell you. For those of you guys wanting to know what we're doing today. It is Business Ethics, season five, episode three. Oh, yeah. It is written by Ryan Coe and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. Love it.
你正试图重新融入社会。你知道的，我喜欢时髦的工装裤，除了裤裆太长。我们今天要做什么？好吧，我来告诉你。对于那些想知道我们今天要干什么的人。这是第五季第三集《商业道德》。哦，是的。这是由瑞安·科e编剧，杰弗里·布里茨执导的。太棒了。
Here is a summary. Jim reluctantly reveals him and Pam's engagement to the office. We'll discuss. Following Ryan's recent actions, corporate has required Holly to conduct a seminar on business ethics. Michael offers immunity to anyone willing to confess to dishonesty at work. What are we like an episode of Survivor? I know you get immunity. Everything you say. And then we're going to light the torch for you. Well some things are revealed. Again, we will discuss. And it's going to cause a rift between
这是剧情梗概。吉姆很不情愿地向办公室公开了他和帕姆订婚的消息。我们待会儿讨论。由于瑞安最近的行为，公司要求霍莉开展一场关于商业道德的研讨会。迈克尔向任何愿意承认在工作中有不诚实行为的人提供豁免权。我们这是在拍《幸存者》吗？我知道你得到了豁免权。你说的所有话。然后我们要为你点燃火炬。好吧，有些事情被揭露了。再次说明，我们要讨论这个。这将会导致
Michael and Holly. Yeah. us and it's going to cause a rift between Michael and Holly. Meanwhile, Jim makes Dwight observe the company's time theft policy and Meredith provides outback steakhouse takeout to the entire office. So that's our summary. Would you like fast fact number one? I really would. All right. New writer alert. Writer Ryan Coe has joined the staff for season five. Hello, Ryan. Welcome.
迈克尔和霍莉之间产生裂痕。是的。我们之间，而且这会导致迈克尔和霍莉之间产生裂痕。与此同时，吉姆让德怀特遵守公司的防盗窃政策，梅雷迪思为整个办公室提供了澳拜客牛排的外卖。这就是我们的梗概。你想听第一条快讯吗？我真的很想。好的。新编剧警报。编剧瑞安·科e加入了第五季的制作团队。你好，瑞安。欢迎。
Hello, Ryan. He was only with us for one season as he left to work on Cougar Town. Oh, we knew lots of folks on Cougar Town. We sure did, Busy Phillips. Oh, yeah. He is also a writer and co-executive producer of The Simpsons. Welcome, Ryan. Welcome.
你好，瑞安。他只和我们合作了一季，就离开去制作《美洲狮镇》了。哦，我们认识好多《美洲狮镇》的人。我们当然认识，比茜·菲利普斯。哦，是的。他同时也是《辛普森一家》的编剧和联合执行制片人。欢迎，瑞安。欢迎。
Fast fact number two, no Pam. Outside of the cold open where you hear Pam's voice, there is no Pam in this episode. But there was Pam. There was, you guys. There was. I filmed a bunch of scenes at art school and they all got cut out. I know. I saw in the deleted scenes. There's like three. Well, I'm going to talk about them. Okay. As we break down this episode, on Office Ladies, Pam will be inserted into this episode again. She will live again. She will. And also, Jenna, there was an amazing Ryan Kevin runner that got deleted for time.
第二条快讯，没有帕姆。除了你能听到帕姆声音的冷开场外，这一集里没有帕姆。但其实是有帕姆的。有的，伙计们。有的。我在艺术学校拍了一堆戏，但全都被剪掉了。我知道。我在删减片段里看到了。大概有三个。好吧，我会聊聊这些的。好的。在我们剖析这一集时，帕姆将再次被融入这一集。她将再次活过来。她会的。而且，珍娜，还有一个精彩的瑞安与凯文的支线情节因为时长被删掉了。
And it's great. And I'm going to bring that up. You guys, we're bringing it all back today in Business Ethics. Fast fact number three, Amy Ryan! Holly is here today! We interviewed Amy Ryan all about this episode and her time on The Office. Let's hear it. Amy Ryan, welcome to Office Ladies. Hi, Office Ladies. I'm so glad to be here and to see your beautiful faces and the interior of your closets. Yeah, I was going to say, welcome to our closets. Amy, it's so good to see you. Holly Flax.
这真的很棒。我要把它提出来。伙计们，我们今天在《商业道德》中把这一切都带回来。第三条快讯，艾米·瑞安！霍莉今天来了！我们采访了艾米·瑞安，聊了聊这一集以及她在《办公室》的时光。我们来听听。艾米·瑞安，欢迎来到“办公室女士”。嗨，“办公室女士”。我很高兴能来到这里，见到你们美丽的脸庞以及你们衣橱的内部。对，我想说的是，欢迎来到我们的衣橱。艾米，很高兴见到你。霍莉· flax。
Oh my gosh. Hollis. We found out your name is Hollis. Is that right? Because it's on your little name placard. Yes! I don't know if I ever knew that. That's a really good tip. Would you have played the character differently? Tohna, I would have been much more, you know, refined. I feel like Hollis is much more refined
哦，天哪。霍莉丝。我们发现你的名字叫霍莉丝。是这样吗？因为写在你的小名牌上。是的！我不知道我以前知不知道这一点。这是一个非常好的提示。你会把这个角色演得不一样吗？托娜，我会更，你知道的，文雅得多。我觉得霍莉丝要文雅得多
and maybe I would have had an accent. I think if your character had been a Supreme Court judge, you might have gone by Hollis. Yes. But you ended up in HR, and so you went with the less formal Holly, maybe. That's correct. Yeah. When you run HR, you really want to be more approachable, kind of a, warm fuzzy character. That makes sense. Holly was a warm fuzzy character
也许我会带点口音。我想如果你的角色是一个最高法院法官，你可能会叫霍莉丝。是的。但你最后去了人力资源部，所以你可能选了不那么正式的霍莉。确实如此。是的。当你负责人力资源时，你真的希望自己更平易近人一点，成为一个温暖亲切的角色。这说得通。霍莉是一个温暖亲切的角色
and we're in love with her. I am so enamored by Holly and Michael. Jenna and I have cried because Michael is like finally with someone that cares about him. She does. Well, in watching it episode by episode and just four years of Michael not having a partner to suddenly see a woman partner with him
我们都爱她。我太喜欢霍莉和迈克尔了。珍娜和我曾经感动得流泪，因为迈克尔终于和真正关心他的人在一起了。她是这样的。嗯，一集一集地看下来，经历过四年迈克尔没有伴侣的日子，突然看到一个女人愿意成为他的伴侣
and joke with him and like his jokes, I cried. In preparation for meeting you both today, I rewatched the episode. I hadn't watched the show in a long time. We saved her like popping in the room when my daughter was on her third pass of the series. But it is so moving. I think all the characters are so moving.
跟他开玩笑，喜欢他的笑话，我哭了。为了今天能和你们两位见面，我重看了一集。我已经很久没看过这部剧了。我们保存了她闯入房间的那段，当时我女儿正在看第三遍全剧。但这真的很感人。我觉得所有的角色都太感人了。
I know everyone's talked about this before, but that element of the family, it's not a workplace, it's actually a family. And that really comes through so beautifully. But Holly and Michael, I mean, I've always said, you know, there's a lid for every pot. So they finally found each other, but she has a high tolerance, I suppose, for that kind of guy. Well, we always like to ask people, Amy, how did you come to be on the show?
我知道每个人以前都讨论过这个，但家庭的那个元素，它不仅仅是一个工作场所，它实际上是一个家庭。这一点真的很完美地传达出来了。但霍莉和迈克尔，我的意思是，我总是说，萝卜青菜，各有所爱。所以他们终于找到了彼此，但我想她对那种类型的男人有很高的忍耐度。嗯，我们总是喜欢问别人，艾米，你是怎么加入这部剧的？
And we did a little research. Paul Lieberstein told us that they came to you, they were huge fans, but that you had simultaneously mentioned to your agent you might like to do our show. Yes. So what was that process? Yeah, how did it go down? That is true. And the timing was eerie, because I did say that to my agent.
我们做了一点调查。保罗·利伯斯坦告诉我们，他们主动找的你，他们是你的超级粉丝，但你同时向你的经纪人提到过你可能想演我们的剧。是的。所以那个过程是怎样的？对，事情是怎么发展的？那是真的。而且时机非常诡异，因为我确实对我的经纪人这么说过。
It was soon after the Oscars and I was like, you know, I'm doing a lot of dramas and if I have any kind of cache right now at this moment, I want to do a comedy and I want to do a comedy like The Office because I was never good at the four-camera sitcom. I just felt too much pressure and it wasn't, like I always feel like characters weren't really rooted in reality the way the office was. And that goes back to how I met Paul Lieberstein. We were both employed on the Naked Truth
那是在奥斯卡颁奖典礼后不久，我说，你知道的，我拍了很多正剧，如果我现在这个时刻还有点名望的话，我想拍喜剧，我想拍像《办公室》这样的喜剧，因为我从来都不擅长四机位情景喜剧。我总是觉得压力太大，而且感觉不够真实，我总觉得那些角色不像《办公室》那样真正植根于现实。这就回到了我是怎么认识保罗·利伯斯坦的。我们当时都在《真相大白》剧组工作
and he was a writer. My agent had kind of reached out and at the same time, Paul had reached out, I guess, to him. I don't know who got there first, but it was, I really think it was like about the same time, Paul had reached out, I guess, to him. I don't know who got there first, but it was, I really think it was like about the same week. And Paul had mentioned that he was also a fan of The Wire, as were some of the other writers.
他是个编剧。我的经纪人联系了他，与此同时，保罗好像也联系了她。我不知道谁先联系的谁，但那真的，我觉得差不多是同一周。保罗曾提到他也是《火线》的粉丝，其他一些编剧也是。
So it was kind of a culmination of all those worlds coming together. And did they pitch the character of Holly to you? Or did you like have a script to read or anything? I don't remember reading a script. I remember saying, hearing it was a one episode only and potential love interest, which obviously I knew was code for, we'll see how you do, kid, if we have you back.
所以这可以说是所有这些世界交汇的一个高潮。他们向你推介霍莉这个角色了吗？还是你有剧本可以读或者别的什么？我不记得读过剧本。我记得听说这只是一个客串一集的角色，而且是一个潜在的恋爱对象，很显然我知道这其实是潜台词：我们看看你表现怎么样，孩子，如果行的话我们会让你回来的。
I remember also because I was a big fan of the British series, David finally gets a woman who likes him too. So it was loosely based, I think, on her for the first episode, and then our group took it to a different level. So there was no script that I was pretty to, but I knew the kind of general idea of it.
我也记得，因为我是英国原版的超级粉丝，大卫终于找到了一个也喜欢他的女人。所以第一集大致是根据她改编的，然后我们团队把它带到了一个新的高度。所以我没有看过任何剧本，但我大概知道整体的想法。
What was it like to walk onto the set for the first time? Really weird. It was really weird. It's because also then I'm now a fan of the American version. And you start to know the set, obviously, from the comfort of your couch or your tablet or whatever it is. When you get there, it's like, oh, everything's smaller.
第一次走进片场是什么感觉？真的很诡异。真的很诡异。因为那时候我也成了美国版的粉丝。显而易见，你开始熟悉这个片场，是从你的沙发、平板电脑或任何东西的舒适环境中。当你到达那里时，就像，哦，一切都变小了。
And then there you all were so warm and welcoming. You know, there's always an element of being the new kid in school and how's that going to go down. But, and I'll see you guys at this point are on a really massive, you know, big hit show. And it was the most down to earth, welcoming, warm group of people, like true ensemble that I met. And even to the end, I feel like you hear all those stories
然后你们所有人都在那里，那么热情和欢迎。你知道，作为一个新来的转学生总会有一种新人的心态，不知道事情会怎么发展。但是，而且我看到你们在这个时候已经是一部非常宏大、非常热播的剧了。这是我见过的最脚踏实地、最热情、最温暖的一群人，真正的一群演员。甚至直到最后，我觉得你会听到所有那些故事
of shows that become so successful and the bad behavior starts coming out. But at least I didn't see any of that. And I just thought it was always about the work, and you guys really set such a beautiful tone there. Well, you said you rewatched Business Ethics and one of my favorite parts is when you and Michael do the let's get physical.
关于那些变得如此成功的剧集，然后糟糕的行为开始出现。但至少我没有看到任何那种情况。我只觉得一切都关乎作品，你们真的在那里定下了一个如此美好的基调。嗯，你说你重看了一遍《商业道德》，我最喜欢的片段之一就是你和迈克尔跳“Let's Get Physical”。
Yes, that's so funny. I watched that with my daughter and we watched that scene like two times in a row, just him reaching in trying to hit the play button With those headbands and your dance number. How did you guys come up with all that? What do we do? I want like it the headbands I have to give credit for wardrobe I mean that was pretty wonderful and ridiculous just that having that visual the dance. Honestly, that's me Just following Steve visual. The dance, honestly, that's me just following Steve. Anything that I was lucky enough to be partnered, paired with Steve, I was smart enough to get in the sidecar of that motorcycle ride. I'm not going to leave this here. He's going to have a better idea. So that was just me kind of He's going to have a better idea. So that was just me kind of, you know,
是的，太搞笑了。我和我女儿一起看了那个，那个场景我们连着看了两遍，就是他伸手试图去按播放键戴着发带，还有你们的舞蹈动作。你们是怎么想出这一切的？我们该怎么做？我想要像发带这种，我得给服装组记上一功，我的意思是这真的是太精彩也太荒谬了，仅仅是拥有那种视觉效果，还有舞蹈。老实说，这就是我跟着史蒂夫做。只要我有幸能和史蒂夫搭档配对，我就足够聪明地去坐那辆摩托车旁边的挎斗。我不会把这个留在这里的。他会有更好的主意。所以那只是我某种程度上他会有更好的主意。所以那只是我某种程度上，你知道的，
literally following his choreography. Well, I wasn't there because my character was at art school. So I am super bummed that I did not get to see that done live. Did you guys do like tons of takes of it? You were there, Ann. Do you guys remember? It was so hard not to laugh. Like from the minute it started and when I was rewatching it,
字面意思上跟着他的编舞走。好吧，我不在那里，因为我的角色在艺术学校。所以我超级遗憾没能亲眼看到现场的表演。你们拍了无数条吗？安，你在场。你们还记得吗？忍住不笑真的太难了。从开始的那一分钟起，当我重看的时候，
Oscar's face says it all. He's in the front. And I was like, I don't want to be in the front. Please don't put me in the front, because I knew I was going to get so tickled. And Oscar does this thing when he's trying not to break. You know, we know each other's tales after all those years where he kind of does this mouth open thing.
奥斯卡的表情说明了一切。他就在前排。当时我就想，我可不想坐在前排。请千万别让我坐前排，因为我知道我会笑得受不了。奥斯卡在努力憋笑的时候会做这样一个动作。经历过那些年之后，我们都知道彼此的习惯，他会做出那种嘴巴微张的表情。
And that's him trying not to laugh. So you go back and watch. Oscar's like, I'm going to. It was so funny. First of all, being in that conference, you know, that's kind of the most famous part of the set, right? Here we go and someone gets to present something and it's better when, again, you're paired with someone next to you but those scenes where I'm alone giving the conference, my hands are like white knuckled. I'm like trying to be like, you know, very casual holding my hands. But if you look closely, my hands are just like two iron fists of nerves. That's the other thing.
那就是他在努力忍住不笑。所以你回去看。奥斯卡就像是，我要。太搞笑了。首先，身处那个会议室，你知道的，那是片场最著名的部分，对吧？我们来了，有人要进行演示，而当你和身旁的人搭档时，效果会更好，但那些我独自一人进行会议的场景，我的手都抓得关节发白了。我尽量表现得很，你知道的，非常随意的样子，把手放好。但如果你仔细看，我的手就像是紧张得握成铁拳。还有一件事。
Everyone always asks me, is the office, was that a lot of improv? And I said, no, it was, I remember scripty coming up to me, you know, correcting me for like, of instead of act, like something really tiny. And I tell people and tell me if I'm wrong, I was like, it was heavily scripted. And then maybe by the third take, Steve would go off script first, and then everyone would follow suit. That's my recollection of it. Do you would you say that's right? Absolutely.
每个人总是问我，《办公室》里是不是有很多即兴发挥？我说，不，我记得剧本统筹走到我面前，你知道的，纠正我一些诸如“of”和“act”之类的细微错误，就像非常微小的词。我告诉人们，如果我错了请纠正我，我说：那是有着厚厚剧本的。然后大概到了第三条，史蒂夫会率先脱离剧本，接着大家就会纷纷效仿。这是我的记忆。你会说这是对的吗？绝对是的。
Yeah. And then, and in that, I just think it was again, like, you guys are so in tune with each other and no one trying to beat anyone to the punchline. It was just a constant setup. It was, I thought it was just so perfect. And I think that's why people can't really tell between the scripted and when it goes to improv. It was just so perfectly done.
是的。而且，在那种情况下，我觉得这再次证明了，你们彼此之间是那么默契，没有人试图抢别人的梗。这只是一个持续的抛接。我认为这实在是太完美了。我想这就是为什么人们真的分不清哪些是剧本台词，哪些是即兴发挥。一切都完成得太完美了。
I wanted to ask you about those restaurant scenes. Oh yeah. Coopers. There's that whole runner about the chastity belt where he's trying to explain what a chastity belt is. Oh my god. And you are like a chastity belt. I think like the really fun part of their relationship is that it's always a surprise when like Holly's on board with him with some joke. And then those moments like the Chassis Belt where she's so horrified and yet so forgiving. Here she is, she's still flirty with this guy and she likes him and not sure where it's going to go, but she's going to give that a pass. You know, always with Steve, it was so hard not to laugh.
我想问你关于那些餐厅的场景。哦，是的。库珀餐厅。那里有一个关于贞操带的完整支线，他试图解释什么是贞操带。哦，天哪。而你的反应就像是一个贞操带。我觉得他们关系中非常有趣的部分是，当霍莉对他的某个笑话表示赞同和配合时，总是会让人感到惊喜。然后像贞操带那样她感到非常震惊却又如此包容的时刻。她就是这样，她仍然在和这个家伙调情，她喜欢他，虽然不确定事情会发展到哪里，但她还是会对此网开一面。你知道的，和史蒂夫在一起时，总是很难忍住不笑。
It was also like a thrill that sets in. Look, I remember when I was 25, I went skydiving and I did it where you're strapped to the other instructor. And just as the airplane door opened up and he made me look out, we were about, I guess, 13,000 feet near and I remember the thought in my head is okay I'm gonna die or I'm gonna have the time of my life, pick one. And I remember picking I'm gonna have fun and as nervous as I was you know being like in those scenes with Steve I remember remember that moment too, like, oh, just
这也伴随着一种油然而生的刺激感。看，我记得我25岁的时候，我去玩了高空跳伞，我是和一个教练绑在一起跳的。就在飞机门打开的那一刻，他让我往下看，我们大概在，我猜，离地13,000英尺的高空，我记得我脑子里的想法是，好吧，我要么会死，要么会度过我一生中最美妙的时光，选一个吧。我记得我选择了我要玩得开心，尽管我很紧张，你知道的，和史蒂夫一起拍那些场景，我也记得那个时刻，就像，哦，只是
pick one. Why don't you have fun instead? You know? And certainly with him at the lead, like, we're all going to look good. You know, he's going to take us along for the ride, I feel. But it was so hard not to laugh, like painfully hard not to laugh with him. But I felt like we were dropped into another place of concentration that kind of pulled it all along, if that makes sense.
选一个吧。为什么不找点乐子呢？你知道吗？当然有他在前面领头，我们所有人都会表现得很出色。你知道的，我觉得他会带着我们一起经历这段旅程。但要忍住不笑真的太难了，痛苦地难以忍住不笑。不过我觉得我们陷入了另一种专注状态，把这一切都支撑下去了，如果这说得通的话。
Yeah. Did you know Steve before? Yeah. In a very, I have this minuscule part in Dan in Real Life that Steve starred in. It was this big, extended family comedy. There was a whole group of us there on location in Rhode Island, and so we all became friends. And then I think it was about six months after that film is when The Office came up. And I believe they ran the idea by Steve of casting me and I guess it helped. I knew him from Rhode Island for that little bit.
是的。你以前认识史蒂夫吗？认识。在一个非常，我在史蒂夫主演的《糊涂绑架案》里演过一个微不足道的小角色。那是一部大型的大家庭喜剧。我们有一大群人都在罗德岛的外景地，所以我们都成了朋友。然后我想大概是在那部电影上映六个月后，《办公室》就找到了我。我想他们把选我的想法告诉了史蒂夫，我想我之前在罗德岛和他的那一小段交情多少帮了点忙。
Well we always ask everyone if they have any like favorite memories from their time on the show like any kind of behind-the-scenes moment or just something that you remember that stood out to you during your time on The Office. Oh my gosh there's so so much I I mean, just in a general note, I would honestly, no exaggeration, I would go home feeling like I worked out a series of sit-ups because my stomach muscles were always in play for laughing so hard. And I just go home exhausted but happy. And that was a nice feeling. it but happy and that was a nice feeling but there's and speaking of that like kind of the uncontrollable laughter there's the episode where Daryl helps me move and he comes in the car ride the truck ride he has yeah me Steve and
我们总是问每个人，他们对在剧组的时光有没有什么最喜欢的记忆，比如任何幕后时刻，或者在《办公室》期间让你印象深刻的事情。哦，天哪，有太多太多了。我的意思是，单就一个普遍的感受来说，我真的毫不夸张地说，我每次回家都感觉自己像是做了一组仰卧起坐，因为笑得太厉害，腹肌一直在用力。我总是筋疲力尽但又很高兴地回家。那真是一种美好的感觉。但有个情况，说到那种无法控制的笑话，有一集是达里尔帮我搬家，他坐上了车，卡车的那趟车，他带着，是的，我和史蒂夫以及
Craig like hold up in that truck all day of, probably we had a little bit of lack of oxygen, but we couldn't, we just, we were in hysterics and could barely get through the scenes. And it was that, that was like one of the highlights of my time there, was just spending the day with those two guys, just laughing. I mean, I say that, but I'd also be on set and laughing all the time too. It was just very new to me. Usually I end up in these dramas where I'm crying all day. So this is a much better way to spend your day.
克雷格在那个卡车里待了一整天，可能我们有点缺氧，但我们停不下来，我们简直歇斯底里，几乎无法把戏演完。那段经历就像是我在那里的高光时刻之一，只是和那两个家伙度过了一天，一直在笑。我的意思是，虽然我这么说，但我也经常在片场笑个不停。这对我来说真的很新鲜。通常我最后都会去拍那种哭一整天的正剧。所以这是一种度过一天的更好方式。
I remember that too. And I remember my agents asking me if I wanted to do dramas in my downtime. You mentioned you were like, I've done a lot of dramas. I want to do a comedy. They were like, do you want to take a stab at some drama? And I was like, I don't think so. I think I'm really liking the jobs where I just laugh all day.
我也记得那个。而且我记得我的经纪人问我，在闲暇时间是否还想拍正剧。你提到过你当时说，我拍了很多正剧。我想拍喜剧。他们问：你想不想尝试一下正剧？我说：我想不用了。我觉得我真的很喜欢那种整天都在笑的工作。
Because I'm like in a good mood a lot. So let's just keep doing the comedies I'm like in a good mood a lot. So let's just, let's keep doing the comedies. It was, it was like, it was a happy place to work. My only request was if I could ever have a scene where I didn't frown. That's true. You had to frown your way through this comedy. Well, do you get recognized as Holly Flax, like when you're out and about? Oh, I do. I do. And it's interesting. I'm sure you guys have noticed that there's being recognized when the show was on the air and then the whole streaming version of the show that has kind of taken it to a whole new level.
因为我大部分时间心情都很好。所以我们就继续拍喜剧吧。我大部分时间心情都很好。所以我们就继续，继续拍喜剧吧。那真的是一个快乐的工作场所。我唯一的请求就是我能不能有一场不用皱眉头的戏。确实如此。你得一路皱着眉头演完这部喜剧。好吧，你走在外面的时候，会被人认出来是霍莉· flax 吗？哦，会的。会的。而且很有趣。我确信你们也注意到了，在剧集热播时被人认出，和后来流媒体播放让这部剧达到了一个全新高度之后的认出，是不一样的。
And everyone's getting younger. My daughter's friends and so yeah, I do. I still get, I still get recognized. You know, years ago, not that long ago, a few years ago, my family and our really good friends, we went to Scranton because there's this amazing antique store called All Good Things. It's just a warehouse, a giant warehouse of just every old antique knob, hinge, dresser, door, toilet. Sign me up, baby. It goes on forever.
而且每个人都变得越来越年轻了。我女儿的朋友们，所以是的，会的。我依然会被人认出来。几年前，其实没那么久，几年前，我和我的家人还有几个非常好的朋友，我们去了斯克兰顿，因为那里有一家名为“一切美好”的惊艳古董店。那只是一个仓库，一个巨大的仓库，里面摆满了各种旧古董旋钮、铰链、梳妆台、门、马桶。算我一个，宝贝。它好像永远也逛不完。
It's really cool. Oh. So we go there, and then we're looking for something to eat more hungry. And they pull in and I was kind of behind the eight ball on this and we we pull into Cooper's. Oh my god. I go I go Oh, no, no, no, you guys know I'm pretty. I mean, I don't get harassed being you know, but I I'm pretty shy. If someone comes up to me on the street, I say hello and thank you. But, but I also have a lot of privacy. People don't always recognize me, but I was like, hell no, I will not going into Coopers. I am Holly from the office. I cannot walk into Coopers. I cannot, I cannot, I cannot.
真的很酷。哦。所以我们去了那里，然后我们开始找吃的，因为我们更饿了。他们开车进去了，我当时有点后知后觉，我们开进了库珀餐厅。哦，天哪。我说，我说，哦，不，不，不，你们知道我很漂亮。我的意思是，作为一个普通人我不会遭到骚扰，但我其实挺害羞的。如果有人在街上走过来找我，我会说你好并表示感谢。但是，我也非常注重隐私。人们并不总能认出我，但我当时想，见鬼去吧，我绝对不进库珀餐厅。我是《办公室》里的霍莉。我不能走进去。我不能，我不能，我不能。
And they're like, and my one friend, Anne was there, she's kind of naughty. She's like, oh, it'll be so good. We have to, we have to. So they talked me into it, but I go in and I've got my head down and I'm just like waiting. I'm waiting to be treated like the Beatles here or something. And we sit in a booth and this old tired waitress comes up and she takes our order.
他们却说，而且我有一个朋友，安也在场，她有点淘气。她说，哦，这会很好玩的。我们必须去，我们必须去。所以他们说服了我，但我还是走了进去，把头埋得很低，只是在等待。我等着在这里被当成披头士乐队或者别的什么人对待。我们在一个卡座坐下，一个疲惫的老服务员走过来记我们的点单。
And my friend Anne right away, she's like, this place is amazing. What's the story here? She's like, oh well, we've been here for X amount of years and it was also used in the set of The Office. But people used to be excited about that, but they're not anymore. What can I get you? I was like, so offended. Not one person recognized me. So offended. Not one person recognized me. I know, not one, not one. And we left. We gave her a good tip and we left and I was like so, so bummed. But anyway, that's my Cooper story. It's pretty cool inside though. I think our set decoration did a pretty great job. The real Coopers is pretty cool, yeah. I think our set decoration did a pretty great job. But the real Coopers is pretty cool. Yeah.
我的朋友安马上说，这个地方太棒了。这里有什么故事吗？她说，哦，我们开了很多年了，这里也曾是《办公室》的取景地。但以前人们还会为此感到兴奋，现在可不会了。你们要点什么？我当时想，太被冒犯了。竟然没有一个人认出我。太被冒犯了。竟然没有一个人认出我。我知道，一个也没有，一个都没有。然后我们就离开了。我们给了她小费，然后离开了，我当时觉得太，太沮丧了。不管怎样，这就是我的库珀餐厅的故事。不过里面真的很酷。我觉得我们的布景设计真的做得非常棒。真正的库珀餐厅确实挺酷的。是的。我觉得我们的布景设计真的做得非常棒。但真正的库珀餐厅确实挺酷。是的。
Well, when people hear this podcast and they realize they might have been at Coopers with Holly Flax and didn't know it, they're going to be like, what day? What day? Oh my God. It's part of like a whole Scranton the Office fan tour now. You know, they have like a whole tour and you can go around Scranton and go to all the spots. Oh my god. Maybe don't go back because maybe it
嗯，当人们听到这个播客，意识到他们可能曾经和霍莉· flax 一起在库珀餐厅吃过饭却浑然不知时，他们一定会想：哪一天？哪一天？哦，天哪。现在这已经成了斯克兰顿《办公室》粉丝游的一部分了。你知道的，他们甚至有一个完整的旅游路线，你可以绕着斯克兰顿参观所有的拍摄点。哦，天哪。也许别再回去了，因为说不定这次
will be the Beatles experience. Amy, before you were going to come on the podcast, I admit I googled you, which is a weird thing to do. It's weird to google someone you know. It is so weird. It's so weird and I, you know, had never done that before, googled you. But I did and I saw all of your stage work
会享受到披头士级别的待遇。艾米，在你来录播客之前，我承认我谷歌过你，这其实是一件很奇怪的事。去谷歌一个你认识的人真的很奇怪。这太奇怪了。这太奇怪了，而且我，你知道的，以前从来没做过这事，去谷歌你。但我确实这么做了，我看到了你所有的舞台作品
and stage experience, which I knew that you did theater, but I didn't know that you got your first touring job right out of school that you toured with Biloxi Blues. Right out of high school. Yeah. So did you ever have like that day job? Did you ever have or were you able to work pretty consistently as an actress right out of school?
和舞台表演经验，虽然我知道你演过话剧，但我不知道你一毕业就拿到了第一份巡演工作，跟着《比洛克斯伊蓝调》去巡演了。高中一毕业。对。那你以前有过那种日常朝九晚五的工作吗？你有没有过，还是说你一毕业就能作为演员稳定地工作？
Yeah. So I went to a performing arts high school in New York. And then a month or so after graduation, I was cast in the touring company of Biloxi Blues. And I toured for nine months and thought, well, that's easy. I'll work all the time, I guess. I didn't work for a long time afterwards, but after the tour, I was still only like 18, 19, so I went back home,
是的。我上了纽约的一所表演艺术高中。然后在毕业大约一个月后，我被选中加入了《比洛克斯伊蓝调》的巡演剧团。我巡演了九个月，心想，哇，这太容易了。我想我会一直有工作。在那之后的很长一段时间里我都没有工作，但巡演结束后，我其实也才18、19岁，所以我回了家，
so I didn't have rent. My family, we lived in New York, so I was able to afford a life in New York by just being an actor and doing acting jobs until I moved out of the house in my mid-30s. I know. I'm very lucky. I've only ever been an actor. Say before high school graduation, I worked in my aunt and uncle's ice cream shop in Vermont when I was 16. But yeah, acting's been my only job. That's amazing. It's kind of weird, but I do think of how any young actor,
所以我没有房租压力。我的家人住在纽约，所以我可以通过做演员和表演工作来负担在纽约的生活，直到我三十岁出头搬出家门。我知道。我真的很幸运。我这辈子只当过演员。高中毕业前，我在佛蒙特州我阿姨和叔叔的冰淇淋店里打过工，那时我16岁。但对，表演一直是我唯一的工作。太神奇了。这听起来可能有点奇怪，但我确实在想，任何年轻的演员、
artist moves to LA, moves to New York from other places or to Chicago with, I always think of that person like suitcase in hand and room share list. My hat just goes off to them because it's so hard. It's so hard. I don't know how people do it. You know, I was lucky that I already lived in New York and could go home for home cooked meals and all that kind of stuff. But I'm glad they're doing it somehow. Are you working on anything now, Amy? I just finished this new first season of this Hulu series called Only Murders in the Building
艺术家来到洛杉矶、纽约或者芝加哥，我总是会想到那些手里拎着行李箱、找合租房的人。我真的向他们致以最崇高的敬意，因为这太难了。太难了。我不知道人们是怎么坚持下来的。你知道，我很幸运，因为我本来就住在纽约，可以回家吃家常饭菜之类的。但我很高兴他们无论如何都坚持下来了。艾米，你现在在忙什么吗？我刚刚拍完Hulu剧集《大楼里唯一的谋杀案》的第一季，
with Steve Martin and Martin Short and Selena Gomez. And it was, again, like, it was a throwback to, like, again, Jenna, like you say, like, doing the comedies, like, oh, this feels fun. I'm in a good mood. And certainly shooting through a pandemic, you know, it was, I wouldn't want to be on a heavy drama right now. It's just too intense. But it was, it was a joy to be around those people during this time.
合作演员有史蒂夫·马丁、马丁·肖特和赛琳娜·戈麦斯。这又一次，就像是回到了过去，就像珍娜你说的，拍喜剧的感觉，哦，这感觉太有趣了。我心情很好。而且在疫情期间坚持拍戏，你知道的，我可不想现在去拍一部沉重的正剧。那实在太紧张了。但在这段时期能和那些人在一起，真是一件令人快乐的事。
And so, but that's it. And I don't know, I don't know what I'll do next. You know, even after 33 years, like I never know what's next. So, we'll see what happens. Well, Amy, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies and sharing your memories of being on the show. It was so cool to be back in touch with you and see you again. Oh, same here. I really miss you guys and I hope all's well with your families and I hope to see you in person. Yes, that would be amazing. Jenna and I have said we want to do like an office ladies lunch,
所以，就是这样。而且我不知道，我不知道接下来会做什么。你知道，即使经历了33年，我依然不知道接下来会发生什么。所以，我们走着瞧吧。嗯，艾米，非常感谢你能来到“办公室女士”分享你在剧组的回忆。能够重新和你联系并再次见到你，真的太棒了。哦，我也是。我真的很想念你们，希望你们的家人一切都好，也希望有机会能亲自见到你们。对，那太棒了。珍娜和我曾经说过，我们想办一个“办公室女士”午餐会，
like call up all the gals and have a lunch. Would that be so fun? Yeah. Oh gosh. Well, let's do it. Let's do it. Thank you so much, Amy. Thanks for having me on your show. I miss you all and hope to see you soon. That was so great. I love her. I love her.
就像把所有的姐妹们都叫来吃顿午餐。那会有多有趣？是的。哦，天哪。好吧，我们办吧。我们办吧。非常感谢你，艾米。谢谢你邀请我上你的节目。我很想念你们所有人，希望很快能见到你们。太棒了。我太爱她了。我太爱她了。
You know, when we got finished with that interview, you guys, I asked her what color were her walls, because her room, it was like painted all this, like kind of dark blue gray color. Kind of a navy blue. It's very cozy looking. I know, and she was in a red dress and her hair was perfect. I kind of want to get that bob.
你知道的，结束那个采访之后，伙计们，我问她墙壁是什么颜色的，因为她的房间，刷成了那种，有点像深蓝色灰色的颜色。有点像海军蓝。看起来非常舒适。我知道，而且她穿着一件红裙子，发型完美无瑕。我有点想剪那个波波头了。
I don't know if I can pull it off. It was such a cute bob. It was. Well, you know, obviously we're going to put the photos from our Zoomie Zoom in the Instagram. Yeah, so you can see it all. The wall, the bob, it's coming at you. Okay, before we get into this episode, I need to share with you who was on the DVD commentary. Oh.
我不知道我能不能驾驭得了。那个波波头太可爱了。确实如此。好吧，你知道的，我们显然会把我们Zoom视频里的照片发到Instagram上。是的，这样你们就能看到了。墙壁，波波头，都在向你们走来。好的，在我们进入这一集之前，我要跟你们分享谁在DVD评论音轨里。哦。
But I'm going to let BJ tell you. What? Welcome to the commentary on business ethics. This is BJ Novak speaking, and this is a very special commentary because I have with me here four of the most beloved crew members on the office to give us a behind the scenes look at how things go,
不过我要让BJ来告诉你们。什么？欢迎收听关于《商业道德》的评论音轨。我是BJ·诺瓦克，这是一期非常特殊的评论音轨，因为我身边有《办公室》里四位最受爱戴的剧组成员，他们将带我们从幕后看看事情是如何运作的，
not just with this episode, but every day for the past 100 episodes. So seated with me, why don't we make introductions from my left. Vortan Chikilian. Peter Evangelatos. Sergio Gokoman. Alan Mork.
不仅是这一集，还有过去100集里的每一天。所以坐在我身边，我们从我左手边开始介绍一下吧。沃坦·奇基连。彼得·埃万杰拉托斯。塞尔吉奥·戈科曼。艾伦·莫克。
And here's how it works. I know. Oh my God. I know. I know. I had the same reaction. And their voices are on the whole thing. Yes. My goodness, I did not expect it. I know, I know.
事情就是这样。我知道。哦，天哪。我知道。我知道。我当时也是这个反应。而且他们的声音贯穿了整段音频。是的。天哪，我完全没有料到。我知道，我知道。
I texted BJ. I said, BJ, I have teared up. I have laughed. I have had every emotion. Oh guys, okay. We should say who they are. Okay, so Peter and Vartan, they did our craft services. They provided the cast and crew with snacks, drinks,
我给BJ发了短信。我说，BJ，我落泪了。我笑了。我有过各种各样的情绪。哦，伙计们，好吧。我们应该说说他们是谁。好吧，彼得和沃坦，他们负责我们的后勤餐饮。他们为演员和剧组成员提供零食、饮料、
meals, anything that you could want and fed us in overtime. We called them the snack masters. Peter was so beloved to us. He was like our grandpa. And he took such good care of us. He passed away a few years ago. Our cast and crew were heartbroken. We loved this man. And it was a delight to get to hear his voice in this DVD commentary. I felt like I spent an evening with him when I rewatched it and I texted BJ immediately. And he said, Oh my God, Angela, where is this? Where can I hear it? Where does it live?
餐食，任何你想要的东西，并在我们加班时给我们提供食物。我们称他们为“零食大师”。彼得对我们来说太亲切了。他就像我们的爷爷一样。他把我们照顾得无微不至。他几年前去世了。我们的演员和剧组都心碎了。我们深爱这个人。能在这次DVD评论音轨里听到他的声音，真是一大幸事。我重看的时候感觉就像和他度过了一个晚上，我立刻给BJ发了短信。他说，哦，天哪，安吉拉，这是哪里？我在哪里能听到？它保存在哪里？
He said, I'm so happy it made you happy. He said, I'm so happy it made you happy. He said, I'm so happy it exists. And he said that he pitched that Peter and Vartan and Sergio and Alan do this commentary. And people were like, what? No, you're crazy. But he was like, you know, like they are like our sustenance. They took such good care of us. We should say Sergio and Alan.
他说，我太高兴这能让你开心了。他说，我太高兴这能让你开心了。他说，我太高兴它存在了。他还说，是他提议让彼得、沃坦、塞尔吉奥和艾伦来录制这段评论音轨的。当时人们的反应是：什么？不，你疯了吧。但他却觉得，你知道的，他们就像是我们的衣食父母。他们把我们照顾得太好了。我们应该说说塞尔吉奥和艾伦。
Yes, they were big time catering. And they fed us lunch and breakfast. They did our big main meals, breakfast and lunch, and Peter and Vartan did everything in between. And I really want to share with you what all they talked about on the DVD commentary. They talked about food the whole entire episode. I learned nothing about the actual episode, but I learned what everyone has for breakfast in people's particular like request. And it was so delightful.
是的，他们负责大型餐饮。他们给我们提供午餐和早餐。他们负责我们的主正餐，早餐和午餐，而彼得和沃坦则负责介于两者之间的一切。我真的很想跟你们分享他们在DVD评论音轨里都聊了些什么。他们整集都在聊食物。我关于实际的剧情什么都没学到，但我知道了每个人早餐都吃什么，以及大家具体的饮食要求。这真的太有意思了。
And I think the office fans are going to love this. You got to say, you have to share. Okay, okay, here we go. And then I promise we will get to business ethics, you guys. Okay, first of all, we love people's process. How is their day started? What do they do? Sergio and Alan shared that they got to set very, very early.
我觉得《办公室》的粉丝一定会喜欢这个。你得说，你得分享一下。好吧，好吧，我们开始吧。然后我保证我们马上就讲《商业道德》，伙计们。好的，首先，我们喜欢了解人们的流程。他们的一天是怎么开始的？他们做什么？塞尔吉奥和艾伦分享说，他们到片场的时间非常非常早。
Well, we knew this. I looked up our call sheets. You guys know I have digital clutter. I have all of our call sheets for years. Average cast call time started at 5 a.m. That meant hair and makeup had to be there at 4 a.m. That meant that Sergio and Alan had to have a full breakfast ready at 4 a.m. So they would go to bed at 7 p.m. and get up between midnight and 1 a.m. to be at work at 2 a.m. to start cooking. Alan said every morning I was
好吧，我们知道这个。我查了我们的通告单。你们知道我有数字杂物。我有我们多年来的所有通告单。演员平均通告时间从早上5点开始。这意味着发型和化妆团队必须在早上4点到场。这意味着塞尔吉奥和艾伦必须在早上4点准备好一顿全套早餐。所以他们会在晚上7点睡觉，在半夜12点到凌晨1点之间起床，以便在凌晨2点到达工作岗位开始做饭。艾伦说每天早上我都在
cooking bacon at 3 a.m. and they kind of Alan said every morning I was cooking bacon at 3 a.m. And they kind of joked that he was like Michael Scott. He like woke up and had to start cooking bacon. But you know, they fed breakfast to around 150 people. Yep, because the crew got a hot breakfast as well. Yeah, everybody, everybody, cast and crew. Sergio and Alan, like BJ would just mention someone's name and they knew their breakfast order.
凌晨3点煎培根。他们有点……艾伦说每天早上我都在凌晨3点煎培根。他们还开玩笑说他就像迈克尔·斯科特。他醒来就得开始煎培根。不过你知道的，他们要为大约150人提供早餐。对的，因为剧组人员也可以吃热腾腾的早餐。是的，每个人，所有人，演员和剧组。塞尔吉奥和艾伦，就像BJ随便说出一个人的名字，他们就知道那人的早餐点单。
Oh, say. Okay. Ready? Yeah. Steve would have mushrooms, ground turkey, egg white scramble with a side of ketchup. Okay. Rain would have a veggie scramble with egg whites and one piece of wheat toast. Mm.
哦，说吧。好的。准备好了吗？是的。史蒂夫要蘑菇、碎火鸡肉、炒蛋白，旁边配番茄酱。好的。雷恩要蔬菜炒蛋白，加一片全麦吐司。嗯。
Jenna. Yes? Would have two egg whites scrambled with a little bit of cheese. That's true. Paul Lieberstein would have an egg white scrambled with onions and peppers with Sergio's famous homemade salsa on the side. We weren't very into egg whites as a cast. I'm discovering.
珍娜。到你了？要两个炒蛋白，加一点点奶酪。确实如此。保罗·利伯斯坦要加了洋葱和彩椒的炒蛋白，旁边配上塞尔吉奥著名的自制莎莎酱。我们作为演员其实对蛋白没有那么热衷。我发现这一点了。
Oh, keep it coming. Kate had egg white scrambled with turkey bacon. Oscar, curve ball,, Grilled Cheese with Tomato, Amy Ryan, who's our guest this week, Spinach and Egg Scramble. Now some cast members had their breakfast order become classics because they became so popular. Okay. Okay. So you could order these three.
哦，继续说。凯特要加火鸡培根的炒蛋白。奥斯卡，出其不意，烤奶酪配番茄。艾米·瑞安，我们这周的嘉宾，菠菜炒蛋。现在，有些演员的早餐点单成了经典，因为它们太受欢迎了。好的。好的。所以你可以点这三种。
We've already discussed the Rashida Special. Yes. Remember, invented by Rashida, Black Beans, Turkey beans, turkey bacon, avocado, egg whites, Sergio salsa, two corn tortillas on the side. All right. This is a Rashida. It was the most popular. Okay. Okay. The Rashida special. Inventing the most popular. Yes. In fact, it was like one of Mindy's regular orders was the Rashida. Okay. The Johnny K invented by John Krasinski, tomatoes
我们已经讨论过“拉希达特制”了。是的。记住，由拉希达发明，黑豆，火鸡豆，火鸡培根，牛油果，蛋白，塞尔吉奥的莎莎酱，旁边配两个玉米饼。好的。这就是拉希达特制。这是最受欢迎的。好的。好的。拉希达特制。发明了最受欢迎的。是的。事实上，明迪的常点菜单里就经常有拉希达特制。好的。“强尼K特制”，由约翰·卡拉辛斯基发明，西红柿
and broccoli with egg whites and a little cheddar cheese. Hmm. Sounds kind of gross. I don't want to eat broccoli first thing in the morning. I don't know. I'm not going to lie. There were a few times I would cross over here and make up with John. It didn't smell good. It's coming back to me now. It didn't smell good. Okay, the Creed special, I learned something.
和西兰花配蛋白，再加一点切达干酪。嗯。听起来有点恶心。我可不想一大清早就吃西兰花。我不知道。我不会说谎。有几次我在化妆间和约翰擦身而过。味道不太好。我现在的记忆开始恢复了。味道确实不好。好的，“克里德特制”，我学到了一点。
Creed is apparently a big goat cheese fan. He loves goat cheese. In the morning? Oh yeah, so they said that he would have goat cheese, spinach, onions, and egg whites with green tea. Oh. They also shared the two cast members who were always there the earliest. Oh, let me guess.
克里德显然是个山羊奶酪超级粉丝。他很喜欢山羊奶酪。大清早就吃？哦，对，他们说他会吃山羊奶酪、菠菜、洋葱和蛋白，配一杯绿茶。哦。他们还分享了总是最早到达片场的两个演员。哦，让我猜猜。
Okay. Kate and Phyllis. Leslie and Phyllis. Okay. And, you know, I looked at the call sheets. Leslie, Phyllis, me, and Kate were always called in at 5 a.m. Mm-hmm. Okay, the four of us.
好的。凯特和菲利斯。莱斯利和菲利斯。好吧，而且，我看过通告单。莱斯利、菲利斯、我和凯特总是被安排在早上5点出工。嗯哼。好吧，我们这四个。
I clearly didn't make the early list. But Leslie would order his breakfast at 445.m. Okay, the four of us. I clearly didn't make the early list. But Leslie would order his breakfast at 445. Wow. Yeah. Sergio and Alan also did a huge lunch with multiple meat, fish, veggie choices, salad bar, dessert bar. But they said there was one item they featured just on a whim at the dessert table and it became incredibly popular. And if they wouldn't have it, people would like get like annoyed. They'd be like, where is it? Can I guess? Yeah.
显然我没进早起名单。不过莱斯利会在4点45分点他的早餐。好吧，我们这四个。显然我没进早起名单。不过莱斯利会在4点45分点他的早餐。哇。是的。塞尔吉奥和艾伦还负责一顿丰盛的午餐，有多种肉类、鱼类、蔬菜可供选择，还有沙拉吧、甜品吧。但他们说甜品桌上有一个单品是他们一时兴起推出的，结果变得极其受欢迎。如果他们没有准备这个，人们就会觉得很烦。他们会问：那个在哪儿？我能猜吗？是的。
Was it the warm chocolate chip cookie bar? Yes. Yes. It was the chocolate chip cookie cake. And they served it like hot and melted and kind of gooey. It was so good. You guys, the chocolate chip cookie cake was Steve Carell's kryptonite? I don't know. This guy would eat so healthy, but he had to eat this chocolate chip cookie cake. This is one treat. But literally they said they didn't think much about it.
是温热的巧克力豆曲奇饼干盘吗？是的。是的。就是巧克力豆曲奇蛋糕。他们把它加热融化，有点黏糊糊的那种端上来。真的太好吃了。伙计们，巧克力豆曲奇蛋糕简直是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的克星？我不知道。这家伙平时吃得那么健康，但他偏要吃这个巧克力豆曲奇蛋糕。这就是唯一的犒赏。但字面意思上他们说一开始根本没把它当回事。
They made it one time and then everyone was like, where is it? Where is it? They had to make it like every day. So now I have to talk about Peter and Vartan. They were the snack masters. They had kind of like a full kitchen right on the set, right outside the Dunder Mifflin bullpen. Yep.
他们只做了一次，然后每个人都在问：那个在哪儿？那个在哪儿？他们不得不每天都做。现在我必须得说说彼得和沃坦了。他们是零食大师。他们就像在片场直接拥有了一个完整的厨房，就在德福林办公区的外面。没错。
You know, they had a fridge, you could have cereal, they had milk that you could make your own sandwich, but they would also have a little food bar. And here's what they had to share. Peter talked about how he had been in the business forever. He also said, I thought this was kind of funny, that our cast, we were tea obsessed. He had hundreds of different types of teas. And you might have noticed
你知道的，那里有个冰箱，你可以吃麦片，有牛奶，你可以自己做三明治，但他们还会设一个小吃吧。以下是他们分享的内容。彼得谈到他在这一行待了很久。他还说，我觉得这挺搞笑的，我们剧组的人对茶有着狂热的执着。他准备了上百种不同类型的茶。你可能已经注意到了
that I didn't make Sergio and Alan's breakfast list. Because you would never eat an egg in the morning. Because Peter and Vartan got donuts every morning. So I would go get a donut from Peter and Vartan. Also, BJ liked the Porto's coffee cake. And then Peter said, sometimes he would make UNI sandwiches. He would. And he said, he loved doing it. And he would put them on a porcelain plate and bring them to us. I'm crying again. I know. I know. He took such good care of us. I know, I know. He took such good care of us. I can't explain to you, like the care with which he would make us a sandwich. It's
我没有出现在塞尔吉奥和艾伦的早餐名单上。因为你早上绝对不吃鸡蛋。因为彼得和沃坦每天早上都会准备甜甜圈。所以我经常去彼得和沃坦那里拿个甜甜圈。另外，BJ喜欢波托斯的咖啡蛋糕。然后彼得说，有时他会做金枪鱼三明治。他确实会做。并且他说，他很喜欢做这个。他会把它放在瓷盘里给我们端过来。我又开始哭了。我知道。我知道。他把我们照顾得太好了。我知道，我知道。他把我们照顾得太好了。我无法向你们解释，那种为我们做三明治时的用心。这
so silly and simple, but he would. He'd put it on a porcelain plate and he'd always like garnish it with some cute little like fruit or like a little pickles. Like he'd cut fruit into a shape. Yeah. It really was. It was like your grandpa made you a sandwich. It really was. And you felt so loved. He was so happy to do it. He said that he would make you a tuna fish sandwich and he'd make me ham and cheese.
听起来很傻很简单，但他真的会这么做。他会把它放在瓷盘上，并且总是会用一些可爱的小水果或者小泡菜来点缀。就像他把水果切成某种形状。是的。真的就是这样。就像你爷爷为你做了一个三明治一样。真的就是这样。你会觉得自己被深深地爱着。他做这件事时感到非常高兴。他说他会为你做一个金枪鱼三明治，然后会为我做火腿奶酪三明治。
I cried through this commentary, Jenna. I laughed so hard because Peter and Vartan give each other like such a hard time lovingly and they're so funny. Alan called them the Middle Eastern odd couple because Peter is from Greece and Vartan is from Iraq. They had a hilarious banter, the two of them. They also talked about their infamous 10 a.m. hot snack. Hot snack. Oh my gosh. Peter said they like to mix it up every day. He said on Mondays, for example, there'd be tacos and burritos. One of the most popular hot snack items was?
珍娜，我听这段评论音轨时一直在哭。我笑得那么厉害，因为彼得和沃坦互相开玩笑的方式充满了爱意，而且他们太搞笑了。艾伦称他们为中东版的“冤家路窄”，因为彼得来自希腊，而沃坦来自伊拉克。他们两个人的互动非常搞笑。他们还谈到了他们那臭名昭著的上午10点热乎小吃。热乎小吃。哦，天哪。彼得说他们喜欢每天换着花样来。比如他说周一会有塔可和卷饼。最受欢迎的热门小吃之一是什么？
Albanda gauze soup. Well, they talked about that, but they said they're turkey chili. Oh! They said they're turkey chili. They had to serve twice a week. People wanted it. They loved it.
肉丸汤。好吧，他们谈到了那个，但他们说那是他们的火鸡辣椒汤。哦！他们说是他们的火鸡辣椒汤。他们一周得供应两次。大家都想吃。他们太爱了。
Ed Helms in particular loved the turkey chili and he came up with a little tip. What is it? Ed, you know, they had garnishes on the side for the chili. They had shredded cheese and they had onions. Ed would put the raw onions at the bottom of his bowl, add the hot turkey chili on top and the heat from the chili would caramelize the onions at the bottom. Wow.
特别是埃德·赫尔姆斯非常喜欢火鸡辣椒汤，他想出一个小窍门。是什么？埃德，你知道的，他们为辣椒汤准备了各种配菜。他们有碎奶酪和洋葱。埃德会把生洋葱放在碗底，把热腾腾的火鸡辣椒汤倒在上面，辣椒汤的热量会把底部的洋葱慢慢焦糖化。哇。
It became a thing. So and much like our Dunder Mifflin counterparts, they said the cast and crew had their favorite pizza places to order from if we went to overtime and we got second meal. Steve loved Mulberry's pizza and we all love Barone's pizza. It was a delight, you guys. I just have to tell you, we loved these men so much. I was lucky enough to work with Sergio again when I guest starred on tell you we loved these mints so much. I was lucky enough to work with Sergio again when I guest starred on Mindy's show Never Have I Ever. She still
这成了一大特色。所以，就像我们在德福林办公室的同行一样，他们说如果我们要加班吃第二餐，演员和剧组成员都有自己最喜欢的披萨店可以点餐。史蒂夫最喜欢马尔伯里的披萨，我们所有人都喜欢巴罗恩的披萨。真的太美妙了，伙计们。我必须告诉你们，我们太爱这些人了。我很幸运，当我去客串明迪的剧《好想做一次》时，又能和塞尔吉奥一起工作了。她依然
wants Sergio on her projects. It was so awesome. These guys were our family. Yeah. And they took such good care of us. And if you have ever wondered why the only thing my dad talked about was the food when he visited set, listen to this commentary. I loved that. I loved it too. And I know I went on and on, but I had to share it. I hope everyone else found it interesting because I loved that trip down memory lane. Thank you, Angela. You're welcome. All right. Should we get into this episode? I guess we can. I will pull myself together. Yes. This
想让塞尔吉奥参与她的项目。这真的是太棒了。这些家伙就是我们的家人。是的。他们把我们照顾得无微不至。如果你曾经纳闷为什么我爸爸来片场参观时唯一谈论的话题就是食物，听听这段评论音轨就知道了。我太喜欢那个了。我也很喜欢。我知道我有点滔滔不绝，但我必须分享出来。我希望其他人也觉得有趣，因为我很喜欢那次回忆之旅。谢谢你，安吉拉。不客气。好了。我们该进入这一集了吗？我想我们可以了。我得收拾一下心情。是的。这
episode starts with Jim and Pam on the phone. Pam is kind of mad because nobody congratulated her on her engagement. And Jim says, yeah, I didn't tell anyone. And then he's like, let's tell them. And he puts Pam on speakerphone. And it goes, I think exactly how Jim thought it would go. Yeah, it ends with Michael arriving and hearing the news and tackling Jim to the floor. We got a fan question from Kyle T and Peyton M. How was the stunt done where Michael knocks Jim over with a hug?
一集开始于吉姆和帕姆在通电话。帕姆有点生气的点在于没有人祝贺她订婚。而吉姆说，是的，我没告诉任何人。然后他说，我们告诉他们吧。接着他把帕姆开了免提。事情的发展，我想完全如吉姆所料。是的。结局是迈克尔赶到并听到了这个消息，直接冲过去把吉姆扑倒在地。我们收到了凯尔·T.和佩顿·M.的粉丝提问。迈克尔用拥抱把吉姆撞倒的特技是怎么完成的？
Also, John's face is just amazing. You know, that is a really hard thing to do to know you're going to be tackled, but keep your body relaxed. And not like wits. Yeah. Not expect the tackle. Well, I wasn't there. I was backstage on a phone so I didn't see it go down. Angela, do you remember? Was there like a mattress or something that they landed on? There was a big blue squishy thing. You know what I mean? A big blue square. It looked like a gymnastics kind of map, right? Yeah. But it was so funny. I have to imagine John lost it because John did not do well in scenes
还有，约翰的表情简直太绝了。你知道的，要做到明知自己会被扑倒，却还能保持身体放松，这是一件非常困难的事。而不是一副很僵硬的样子。是的。不是那种期待被扑倒的状态。好吧，我不在场。我在后台打电话，所以没有看到事情是怎么发生的。安吉拉，你还记得吗？他们着陆的地方是不是有什么床垫之类的东西？那里有一个大的蓝色海绵垫。你知道我的意思吗？一个大的蓝色正方形垫子。看起来像体操用的那种垫子，对吧？是的。但太搞笑了。我不得不想象约翰当时肯定笑场了，因为约翰最应付不了那种场景
like that, especially with Steve Blake. My memory of it is they didn't do it very many times. Okay. Well, now we're into the episode. It's Ethics Day. Holly has passed out a form. Everyone has to fill out. She's going to be taken this seriously. She is. She explains that she is going to be running her first meeting. But don't worry. We talked about this with Amy Ryan. Michael's going to help her out and they're going to start it off with their version of Let's Get Physical. With headbands and dancing and a boombox. Jenna, I worked in corporate America. I have been in human resources seminars that we had to go to. I'm telling you, they had skits.
尤其是和史蒂夫在一起时。我的记忆是他们没拍很多次。好吧，现在我们进入这一集。今天是道德日。霍莉发下了一张表格。每个人都得填。她对此非常认真。确实如此。她解释说这是她主持的第一次会议。不过别担心。我们和艾米·瑞安聊过这个。迈克尔会帮她一把，他们将以他们自己的版本“Let's Get Physical”来为会议拉开序幕。戴着发带，跳着舞，还拿着一台音响。珍娜，我在美国企业界工作过。我参加过我们不得不去的人力资源研讨会。我告诉你，他们是有短剧的。
What? When I watched this, I had such a flood of memories coming back of sitting in a tiny little conference room when I worked at this company. and our human resources department, there were two people, they would come in and act out skits of what's inappropriate. We had one guy, his name was Tom, and we had a gal, her name was Susan, and he'd be like, Susan, that skirt looks really nice on you today. Hey, time to party. And then Susan would do a face like, huh? And then they'd freeze.
什么？当我看到这个的时候，记忆如潮水般涌回，我想起当年在这家公司工作时，坐在一个小小的会议室里。我们的人力资源部门有两个人，他们会走进来，通过演短剧来展示什么是不得体的行为。我们有个家伙叫汤姆，还有一个女孩叫苏珊，他会说：苏珊，你今天穿的那条裙子真好看。嘿，派对时间到。然后苏珊会做出一个表情，比如：啊？接着他们会定格。
And then Tom would say, what was inappropriate in this moment? And we'd all have to raise our hands and be like, he was kind of gross about her skirt. I only had to watch like produced videos of weird things. Oh no. I've never seen a live presentation. Oh no, I watched skits.
然后汤姆会说：刚才那一幕有什么不得体的地方？我们所有人都得举手回答：他对她的裙子评头论足，有点恶心。我只需要看那种制作好的、演示各种诡异行为的录像带。哦，不。我从来没看过现场表演。哦，不，我看过短剧。
We had a fan question about this scene from Patricia B. She said, I'm wondering if some of the younger Office fans even know the song that Holly and Michael are performing. She wants to know, Angela, did your kids watch this one with you? Did you have to explain the song parody? Isabel watched it with me. She didn't ask about the song. She just thought it was funny. She probably thinks we made it up.
关于这个场景，我们收到了来自帕特里夏·B.的粉丝提问。她说：我想知道《办公室》的一些年轻粉丝是否知道霍莉和迈克尔表演的那首歌。她想知道，安吉拉，你的孩子们和你一起看这一集了吗？你得向他们解释这首歌的恶搞之处吗？伊莎贝尔和我一起看了。她没有问关于这首歌的事。她只是觉得很好笑。她可能以为那是我们自己编的呢。
Yeah, this was, I guess for our younger listeners, a very famous song by Olivia Newton-John, Let's Get Physical. And the music video was like her in like an aerobics class singing and dancing with a headband. Jane Fonda had like these workout videos at the time too. This was like a little trend. Oh yeah. Sexy working out. But your sexy workout included tights, leg warmers, high tops, leotard, headband, wristband. Yeah. It was a whole thing.
是的，对于我们的年轻听众来说，这曾是一首由奥莉维亚·纽顿-约翰演唱的非常著名的歌曲《Let's Get Physical》。音乐录影带里就像是她在某个有氧操班里，戴着发带一边唱歌一边跳舞。简·方达当时也有这种健身视频。这就像是一个小潮流。哦，是的。性感的健身。但你那性感的健身包括紧身裤、护腿袜、高帮鞋、连体紧身衣、发带、护腕。是的，这可是一整套行头。
It was. I remember it well. Well, Holly begins her ethics meeting by explaining that there's been some misconduct. She's clearly talking about Ryan. Who's been hired again? It's so hilarious, Jean. Yeah.
确实是。我记得很清楚。好吧，霍莉通过解释最近发生了一些不当行为来开启她的道德会议。她显然是在说瑞安。那个又被雇回来的人？这简直太搞笑了，让。是的。
I know. And then she starts going through the results of the quiz. Yeah. Pretty much, she's got this binder. Yeah. And she's got to go through the binder. The HR binder. Yeah. We had a fan question from Peyton M.
我知道。然后她开始过一遍测验的结果。对。差不多吧，她拿着一个文件夹。对。然后她得翻那个文件夹。人事档案夹。对。我们收到了佩顿·M发来的一位粉丝提问。
In the conference room scene, did Creed and Meredith actually break when Stanley said the meeting was a waste of time, or was it scripted for them to laugh? Well, I looked at the script, it was scripted. The script said, people laugh a lot. That was the direction in the script. So the meeting isn't going so great. And Michael's like, you're losing them. Yeah. He pulls Holly aside. You are losing them. They expect a lot. Holly aside, you are losing them. They expect a lot. Yeah, it's really sweet. He's trying to help her in this meeting because he really wants her to succeed. So he says,
在会议室的那场戏里，当斯坦利说开会是在浪费时间时，克里德和梅雷迪思是真的笑场了，还是剧本安排他们笑的？嗯，我看了剧本，是剧本安排的。剧本上写着，大家笑得很开心。剧本里就是这么要求的。所以会议进行得不太顺利。迈克尔就说，你压不住他们。对。他把霍莉拉到一边。你压不住他们。大家的期望很高。霍莉拉到一边，你压不住他们。大家的期望很高。对，这真的很贴心。他在这场会议中试图帮她，因为他真的很希望她能成功。所以他说，
let's get rid of the binder. This is your opportunity to speak up without any repercussions. He's like, guys, what are some things maybe you've done at work to waste time? What have you done? Anything or anything you want to share? Yeah. You have immunity. Go for it. Well, during this time, Michael confesses that he didn't work for five days when he discovered YouTube.
咱们把文件夹扔了吧。这是你们畅所欲言、不用承担任何后果的机会。他说，各位，大家有没有在工作里做过什么来消磨时间的事情？你们都做过什么？有什么想分享的吗？对。你们拥有豁免权。尽管说吧。好吧，就在这个时候，迈克尔承认他发现YouTube以后，有五天时间什么都没干。
It made me laugh so hard. He said he watched Cookie Monster Sings Chocolate Rain about a thousand times. Did you go watch it? I had to know. Of course. Here's the thing. Chocolate Rain, according to its Wikipedia page, was a song by American singer Tay Zonday. I went and watched Tay's last night. Oh, you did. I did. You watched it as well. Yeah. Yes. So he wrote this song and he uploaded a video to YouTube. It was four minutes, 52
这笑死我了。他说他把《饼干怪兽唱巧克力雨》看了大概一千遍。你看过吗？我非得去查查看。当然。事情是这样的。根据维基百科页面，《巧克力雨》是美国歌手泰·宗戴创作的一首歌。我昨晚去看了泰的视频。哦，你看过了。我看了。你也看过了。对。没错。所以他写了这首歌，并把视频上传到了YouTube。时长是四分钟52
seconds long. He uploaded it, everyone, because I know you want to know, April 22nd, 2007. I remember it went viral. Viral. Like before things went viral. It was ranked the hottest viral video of summer 2007, and it was awarded the 2008 YouTube Award in the category of music. So this song then became the subject of like parodies Remixes tributes. It was everywhere even Cookie Monster not Cookie Monster We made that up there was no Cookie Monster sings chocolate rain
秒。大家注意了，因为我知道你们肯定想知道，他是2007年4月22日上传的。我记得它当时火了。火了。在事情真正病毒式传播之前。它被评为2007年夏季最热门的病毒视频，并荣获2008年YouTube音乐类奖项。所以这首歌后来成了各种恶搞、混音和致敬的对象。到处都是，甚至连饼干怪兽——不是饼干怪兽，那是我们瞎编的，根本没有饼干怪兽唱巧克力雨这回事。
They wrote that and after the episode aired, people made them. No way. I didn't know that. Yes. Isn't that crazy? That is crazy. You know, I did go to every version you could imagine of the song. I looked it up and I did notice the one where Cookie Monster is singing it. The first comment said, who else is here because of Michael Scott? Yeah, exactly.
他们写了剧本，在该集播出后，人们真的做出来了。不会吧。我以前不知道。对。是不是很疯狂？太疯狂了。你知道的，我真的去看了你能想象到的这首歌的各种版本。我查了一下，还真注意到有饼干怪兽在唱的版本。第一条评论说，还有谁是因为迈克尔·斯科特才来这里的？对，没错。
Well, Michael has opened the door to confession time and people are just letting it fly. Yeah, the big confession comes from Meredith, who says that she has been having a six year affair with the Hammer Mill rep in exchange for discounts on our supplies and also Outback Steakhouse gift certificates. Bruce Myers. Bruce Myers and Meredith, six years. Now here's something. Wasn't there in that previous episode, we finally landed the hammer mill rep
好吧，迈克尔已经打开了坦白局的大门，大家也都畅所欲言了。对，最大的爆料来自梅雷迪思，她说她跟锤子磨坊的代表有一腿，已经持续六年了，以此来换取我们办公用品的折扣，还有澳拜客牛排馆的礼品卡。布鲁斯·迈尔斯。布鲁斯·迈尔斯和梅雷迪思，六年。现在有个问题。难道在上一集里，我们才刚拿下锤子磨坊的代表吗？
when they went to that big conference and it was only a few. Remember? I think there's a little continuity catch here. Continuity error. Yeah. So she's been sleeping with him for six years, but we only just landed him like two years ago. I don't know, Meredith. Show Bible. Sort it out, guys. Yeah. Holly is troubled. Oh, yeah. Holly is like, this is a serious ethics violation. I have to report this. Jenna, there was one other confession that rattled someone else. What?
当时他们去参加那个大型会议，而且只有几个人。记得吗？我觉得这里有点连贯性漏洞。连贯性错误。对。所以她跟他睡了六年，但我们明明是两年前才签下他的。不知道啊，梅雷迪思。剧集圣经。理一理啊，各位。对。霍莉觉得很不安。哦，对。霍莉觉得，这是严重的违反道德行为。我必须上报。珍娜，还有另一个爆料让人大跌眼镜。什么？
Ryan made a confession and Kevin is like what? This is the beginning of the runner. Sam can you play it? Last year you guys were riding me really hard for the website and I just peeled out my Z3 and I knocked the mirror off somebody's car. I never said a thing. Wait. What? What? Kevin's like what? And then immediately after this conference room scene, Kevin approaches Ryan in the kitchen and confronts him. You knocked the mirror off of my car. Yeah.
瑞安做出了一个爆料，凯文的反应是“什么？”。这就是那个串场小插曲的开始。山姆，你能放一下吗？去年你们为了网站的事把我逼得太紧了，我当时开着我的Z3，结果把别人的反光镜给撞掉了。我一个字都没提。等等。什么？什么？凯文的反应是“什么？”。紧接着这个会议室场景之后，凯文在厨房找到了瑞安并质问他。你撞掉了我车上的反光镜。对。
Isn't that messed up? Yeah. That guy did a lot of things I'm not proud of. Wait. When you say that guy, do you mean you? I mean the guy I used to be. I'm Ryan 2.0. And if it makes you feel any better, that guy did a lot of messed up stuff to me too. You mean that you did a lot of messed up stuff to you. Look, I feel you. Okay? That guy took no responsibility for his actions.
是不是很过分？对。那家伙做了很多让我引以为豪的事。等等。当你指“那家伙”的时候，是指你吗？我是指以前的我。我是瑞安2.0。如果这能让你心里好受点的话，那家伙也对我做过很多过分的事。你是说你自己对自己做了很多过分的事。听着，我理解你，好吗？那家伙对自己的行为不承担任何责任。
But are you gonna pay for my mirror? If I have to answer for everything that guy did, I'm never gonna move on. It was like $200. We're never gonna get what we need from that guy. You know my love of Ryan. Yeah. In this rewatch. And I am so sad that did not make it in the episode,
但你要赔我的反光镜吗？如果我要为那家伙做过的一切买单，我永远也无法向前看了。也就200美元吧。我们永远没法从那家伙身上得到我们想要的东西。你知道我有多喜欢瑞安。对。在这个重刷过程中。我很遗憾这一段没能在正片里播出，
but I am so glad it exists. I know I showed it to Sam and Sam was like, I know these people. I know these people. Yeah, that's a good example of Los Angeles. But yeah, so Kevin gets Ryan back by putting his sunglasses, his really nice sunglasses in the toaster oven. Amazing. Melts them. But that was Kevin 1.0. Yeah, he can't be responsible for what that guy did. That's right.
但我很高兴它存在过。我知道我把它放给山姆看了，山姆说，我认识这些人。我认识这些人。对，那是洛杉矶的一个很好的例子。不过话说回来，凯文通过把瑞安的太阳镜，他那副很好的太阳镜塞进烤面包机里，来报复瑞安。太绝了。融化了。但那是凯文1.0。对，他可不为那家伙做过的事负责。没错。
So that was the Ryan Kevin runner that got deleted because we just ran out of time. But I thought it was so great. It's so good. So now we have the scene where Michael and Holly are going to meet privately with Meredith to discuss her. Liaison. Yes. You know, Michael is trying very hard Holly are going to meet privately with Meredith to discuss her liaison. Yes. You know, Michael is trying very hard to help Meredith say the things she needs
所以这就是那个被删掉的瑞安和凯文的串场，因为我们时间不够了。但我觉它太棒了。太精彩了。所以现在我们看到迈克尔和霍莉要私下跟梅雷迪思见面，讨论她的不正当关系。是的。你知道，迈克尔正在非常努力地——霍莉要私下跟梅雷迪思见面，讨论她的不正当关系。是的。你知道，迈克尔正在非常努力地帮助梅雷迪思说出她需要
to say to get out of trouble. Yeah. Meredith is not getting it. She's not getting it. At all. And Kate is so funny in this scene. So funny. Well, we do have a classic Jim prank. We get a Jim prank. Yeah. It's been a bit, and I thought it was so funny. And I can tell that John and Rain were having such a good time, just because we know them. You gave John that prop, that stopwatch. He's loving that stopwatch. He's loving it.
说的话来脱身。对。梅雷迪思根本没领会。她根本没领会。完全没有。凯特在这场戏里太搞笑了。超级搞笑。好吧，我们确实有一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。我们有一个吉姆恶作剧。对。好久没有了，我觉得这太逗了。我能看出来，约翰和雷恩玩得非常开心，这纯粹是因为我们了解他们。你给了约翰那个道具，那个秒表。他太喜欢那个秒表了。他爱不释手。
Yeah, Dwight had said in the conference room that he doesn't do anything personal at work. He wastes no time. Wastes no time. And so Jim's gonna show him. He's gonna time every single thing he does. Well right about now is when we would have gone to see Pam at art school. And I'm gonna tell you about it. Okay. So Pam and her classmates, they get to class and there's a note on the door, no class today. It's canceled. Cancelled.
对，德怀特在会议室里说过，他在工作时不搞任何私人事情。他绝不浪费时间。不浪费时间。所以吉姆要让他见识一下。他要给德怀特做的每一件事计时。好了，差不多就在这个时候，我们该去看身处艺术学校的潘了。我要跟你们讲讲这事。好的。话说潘和她的同学们，他们去上课，结果门上贴着一张便条，今天没课。取消了。
So her friends are like, let's go get drinks. And Pam's like, I can't. And her friend Alex, who was played by Rich Summer, says, what do you have to do? You're supposed to be in class right now. We know you don't have plans. So they get her to go to this tiki bar for a little day drinking. And I totally remember shooting this, Angela.
所以她的朋友们就说，我们去喝一杯吧。潘却说，我不能去。她的朋友亚历克斯，由里奇·萨默饰演，说，你有什么必须要做的事吗？你现在本来应该在课室里的。我们知道你没有什么计划。于是他们拉着她去了一家蒂基酒吧，在白天喝了点酒。我完全记得当时拍摄的情景，安吉拉。
We're all drinking out of this big giant volcano bowl. There's a flame. It's on fire. We had to have a safety meeting about it. And in the scene, two of the other art students, they're trying to decode this text message. They're wondering what to text back. Well, it's like a guy, right? So she's like wanting to text a guy back, but not seem like too into him.
我们都在从一个巨大的火山碗里喝酒。里面有个火焰。着火了。我们还为此开了一场安全会议。在那个场景里，另外两个艺术生正在试图破译这条短信。他们纳闷该回什么短信才好。好吧，对方是个男的，对吧？所以她想回一个男的短信，但又不想显得太主动。
You know how you have to write the perfect text back to someone you're into, but you don't want to seem too desperate. Well, Pam is spiraling. Remember I said in the other episode that we purposely cast people who would seem younger and hipper than Pam, so she would be this fish out of water in art school? Yeah. Well, she's kind of spiraling about that, and she has this great, crazy monologue that she blurts out.
你知道你怎么才能给心仪的人写出完美的回复，同时又不想显得太绝望。好吧，潘开始钻牛角尖了。还记得我在上一集里说过，我们故意挑选了看起来比潘更年轻、更时髦的演员，好让她在艺术学校里显得格格不入吗？对。好吧，她有点为此陷入纠结，然后她脱口而出了一段精彩、疯狂的独白。
Sam, will you play the Pam tiki bar scene for me? You put a wink at the end. Does that mean something? Mm-hmm. It means she's a dork. So how do I write back, you know, showing them that I'm also a dork? Oh, he knows. Don't ask me.
山姆，你能为我播放一下潘在蒂基酒吧的那场戏吗？你在最后加了个眨眼的表情。那是什么意思？嗯哼。意思是她是个书呆子。那我该怎么回短信，你知道的，向他们证明其实我也是个书呆子？哦，他懂的。别问我。
I don't even know what I'm doing here. I'm like way older than you guys. I mean, like, I have a fiancé and I had, like, a ten-year plan and, like, is graphic design even art? At this point I thought that I would be married and running my own art company. But I just put like big LOL little LOL winky face. Oh okay. Okay I thought that was so interesting. We just got a window into what Pam thought her life would be. She just got a window into what Pam thought her life would be.
我都不知道我在这里干什么。我比你们大好多。我是说，我有个未婚夫，我曾有，比如说，一个十年计划，而且，比如平面设计到底算不算艺术？到了这个阶段，我本以为自己会结婚并经营着自己的艺术公司。但我最后却发了什么“大笑脸”、“小笑脸”加眨眼表情。哦，好吧。好吧，我觉得这太有意思了。我们得以窥见潘原本以为她的人生会是什么样。我们得以窥见潘原本以为她的人生会是什么样。
She says at this point, she thought she would be married and running her own art company. What does she mean by art company? I don't know. It sounds like something like a fifth grader. Like a kid would say. Yeah, like someday I'm gonna own an art company. Does that mean she sells art supplies?
她在这个阶段说，她本以为自己会结婚并经营着自己的艺术公司。她所说的“艺术公司”是什么意思？我不知道。听起来像是五年级小孩会说的话。就像小孩子会说的一样。对，就像“总有一天我要拥有一个艺术公司”。难道意思是她卖美术用品吗？
Yeah. What does she mean by that? I don't know. I thought it was so, it was such a window into Pam, I thought. I did too. And you know, it goes on to show that she drank the whole volcano herself, basically. Yeah. There are more scenes at this bar, she gets really tipsy.
对。她到底是什么意思？我不知道。我觉得这太……这真是一窥潘内心世界的窗口，我觉得。我也是。你知道的，接下来发生的事表明，她基本上把整座“火山”自己一个人喝光了。对。酒吧里还有更多镜头，她喝得酩酊大醉。
But then she has this really peppy talking head where she says if she were in Scranton right now, she'd be an alcoholic, but she's not. She's in New York, so she's a moody artist. She loves New York. Yeah. Well, I was really bummed that these scenes got cut because one of the art students, the guy who you hear trying to help the girl with her text message was played by one of my very good friends in real life, John Cabrera. You might know him because he was a longtime cast member on Gilmore Girls.
但随后她有一个非常神采奕奕的单人访谈，她说如果她现在在斯克兰顿，她早就成酒鬼了，但她没有。她在纽约，所以她是一个忧郁的艺术家。她爱纽约。对啊。好吧，我很沮丧这些场景被剪掉了，因为其中一个艺术生，就是你听到在帮那个女孩回短信的那个男生，由我在现实生活中的好朋友之一乔恩·卡布雷拉饰演。你可能认识他，因为他是《吉尔摩女孩》的长期演员。
He played Brian Fuller. He was the bass player in Lane's band. So we filmed all of these scenes at PAM's art school. They never made it into an episode. He doesn't even have a credit on IMDB for being on the office. Aw. Because all his scenes got cut. But we had the best time. Jenna, have you ever had a volcano?
他饰演布莱恩·富勒。他是莱恩乐队的贝斯手。所以我们拍了所有这些在潘的艺术学校的场景。它们根本没被剪进正集里。他在IMDB上甚至都没有参演过《办公室》的演职员表。噢。因为他的所有戏份都被删了。但我们玩得太开心了。珍娜，你喝过火山鸡尾酒吗？
No. Have you? Once. What? Once in my life. I thought we made that up. That's a real thing. Is it on fire?
没有。你喝过吗？喝过一次。什么？我这辈子就喝过一次。我还以为那是我们编出来的呢。那是真东西。它真的着火了吗？
Yes. Sam is nodding. Like, how many have you had, Sam? So that was the most aggressive I've ever. You are like. Yeah, it's a staple thing. Is it on fire? Yes, it's. Sam is nodding like how many of you had Sam? So that was the most aggressive I've ever. You are like. Yeah, it's a it's a staple of the Tiki bar. Yeah, I've had one. That's all you'll ever need to have. I had one at a bar in Manhattan
对。山姆在点头。就像，你喝过多少个，山姆？所以那是我经历过的最猛烈的。你就像。对，这是一个经典标配。它真的着火了吗？对，它是。山姆在点头，就像你喝过多少个，山姆？所以那是我经历过的最猛烈的。你就像。对，那是蒂基酒吧的标配。对，我喝过一个。那绝对是你需要喝的全部了。我在曼哈顿海滩
Beach for a friend's birthday. We got the volcano because my friend's birthday, you know, we were like 25 years old. It's a huge, huge bowl. It comes on fire, all these different straws in it. It's usually a mixture of like pineapple or grapefruit or lime juice, maple syrup, several different types of rums. I felt real gross the next day. And what's so funny is I had Pam's experience.
的一家酒吧里为一个朋友的生日喝过一个。我们点火山鸡尾酒是因为我朋友过生日，你知道的，我们当时25岁左右。那是一个巨大无比的碗。它带着火焰端上来，里面插着各种各样的吸管。里面通常混合了菠萝汁、葡萄柚汁或青柠汁、枫糖浆，还有好几种不同种类的朗姆酒。我第二天感觉整个人太糟糕了。最搞笑的是，我也有过潘那样的经历。
Like you're just all drinking it and you can't tell who's had more or what, because there's all these straws flopping out of it. And the photos from this evening are real special. We all decided to see if we could do the splits. Oh. Mm-hmm. It was one of those nights. I didn't do the splits. No, you do it. I do it. So volcano guys, tread lightly. Am I too old to have this experience? I think so.
就像你们所有人都在一起喝，根本分不清谁喝了多少或者喝了什么，因为里面插着一堆七倒八歪的吸管。而且那天晚上的照片非常特别。我们所有人都决定试试看自己能不能劈叉。哦。嗯哼。就是那种疯狂的夜晚。我没有劈叉。不，你劈了。我劈了。所以火山鸡尾酒嘛，各位，悠着点。我年纪太大而不能经历这个了吗？我想是的。
Damn it. You won't feel good the next day. I missed my chance. I started drinking late in life. I know. I really did. I think it's okay that you navigated your life without having the volcano experience. I don't know.
该死。你第二天会觉得很不舒服。我错失良机了。我开始喝酒的时间比较晚。我知道。我真的是。我觉得你没经历过火山鸡尾酒，也能把生活过好，这挺正常的。我不知道。
I'm having some FOMO. Well now Michael is going to invite Holly to lunch. Because it's okay if like two attractive people go to lunch, you know, they work together, they're attractive, they can eat lunch. They can eat lunch. It's not an official date. And there was a deleted Michael talking head that if it was an official date, Holly would know because it would go like this. No, this is not an official date. When it is an official date, she will be aware of it. There will be a rose. There will be music and dancing. Bottle of red, bottle of white, bottle of water I've drink more water some whispered conversation some giggling little wine we head back to her place I will skip ahead to protect her dignity but we make hardcore love and then we fall asleep on her one eye
我有点错失恐惧症。好了，现在迈克尔要邀请霍莉去吃午饭。因为两个有吸引力的人一起吃午饭是没问题的，你知道的，他们一起工作，很有吸引力，他们可以吃午饭。他们可以吃午饭。这不是一次正式的约会。还有一个被删掉的迈克尔单人访谈，如果这是一次正式的约会，霍莉就会知道，因为流程会是这样的：不，这不是一次正式的约会。当它是正式约会时，她会意识到的。会有一支玫瑰。会有音乐和舞蹈。一瓶红酒，一瓶白酒，一瓶水——我喝了更多水——一些耳语和窃笑，一点点红酒，我们回到她的住处，我会跳过接下来的部分以保护她的尊严，但我们进行了激烈的爱爱，然后在满月声中在她的（卡壳）上睡着。
to the sound of the full moon. And then chocolate chip pancakes. Okay, I haven't had a volcano, but I've had that date. You've had that date. I've had that date. That's a good date. I just want a shirt that says hardcore love. And you know what?
伴随着满月的鸣响。然后是巧克力豆煎饼。好吧，我没喝过火山鸡尾酒，但我经历过那样的约会。你经历过那样的约会。我经历过那样的约会。那是一次很好的约会。我只想要一件印着“激烈的爱爱”字样的T恤。你知道吗？
You got to fall asleep to the sound of the moon. You do. You do. Well, he suggests that they go to Cooper's Restaurant and I've got some good information to share about that. So why don't we take a break and we'll come back. Great. All right, we are back. Michael and Holly have gone to lunch.
你还得伴随着月亮的声音入眠。确实。必须的。好吧，他建议他们去库珀餐厅，我有一些关于那里的好消息要分享。所以我们休息一下，一会儿回来。太棒了。好了，我们回来了。迈克尔和霍莉去吃午饭了。
We got fan questions from Kelly W, Sammy B, and Carolyn P. What is the restaurant that Holly and Michael went to? Angela, you saw the outside shot of this restaurant. Yeah, I've been there in real life. It is a real restaurant in Scranton called Cooper's Seafood House. And we did not go to Cooper's, so we used a shot of the outside. The interior,
我们收到了来自凯莉·W、萨米·B和卡罗琳·P的粉丝提问。霍莉和迈克尔去的是哪家餐厅？安吉拉，你看到了这家餐厅的外景镜头。对，我在现实生活中去过。那是斯克兰顿一家真实的餐厅，名叫库珀海鲜屋。我们当时没去库珀餐厅，所以我们用了一个外景镜头。内部嘛，
I got all the scoop from Jamesapedia. Jamesapedia is back and Amy Ryan said they did an amazing job. Amazing, right? I looked at pictures online of the real Coopers and I compared them to screenshots because that's what I do now, I guess, is that. Yeah. Yeah. And we really, congratulations to our set designers. They did a great job redressing this. What did Jamesopedia have? Jamesopedia said that we shot the interior at Clancy's Crab Broiler in Glendale, California, that we started shooting at 8 a.m. that day, and there was a note on the call sheet that said,
我从詹姆斯百科（Jamesapedia）那里拿到了所有独家内幕。詹姆斯百科又回归了，艾米·瑞安说他们做得很棒。太棒了，对吧？我在网上看了真正的库珀餐厅的照片，并把它们和截图进行了对比，因为这就是我现在的所作所为吧，大概就是这样。对。对，真的，向我们的布景设计师致敬。他们把这里重新布置得太棒了。詹姆斯百科上都说了什么？詹姆斯百科说，我们在加利福尼亚州格伦代尔的克兰西蟹肉专卖店（Clancy's Crab Broiler）拍摄了内景，那天我们早上8点开始拍摄，通告单上有一条备注写着：
the restaurant will be open for business at 11 a.m. So they had three hours to film all of those restaurant scenes. And I asked him, I said, now when it says they're going to open back up at 11 a.m., does that mean we have to be done filming and get all our stuff out? Because we changed the look of the restaurant. And he said what we would normally do is we would get in there really, really early and dress it, do our scenes, and get out as much as we can by 11 o'clock, but they would go back the next day to do a full cleanup. So the patrons that day ate in a kind of hybrid restaurant of Clancy's Crab Broiler
餐厅将于上午11点开始营业。所以他们有三个小时的时间来拍摄所有这些餐厅的场景。我问他，我说，那当上面写着他们将在上午11点重新开业时，是不是意味着我们必须拍完并把我们所有的东西都搬走？因为我们改变了餐厅的外观。他说，我们通常的做法是，我们会非常非常早地进去布置，拍我们的场景，并在11点之前尽可能多地搬出去，但他们第二天会回去进行彻底的大扫除。所以当天的顾客是在一家介于克兰西蟹肉专卖店
slash Cooper's Seafood. Say that 10 times fast. I could barely say it. Clancy's Crab Broiler. Clancy's Crab Broiler. Well, here's a little something about Cooper's. All right. Brian Baumgartner and I went there in 2007 in Scranton. If you go to Cooper's Seafood House website online, there are a bunch of photos in their gallery section of Brian and I. I saw them. One in particular, I am barefoot
和库珀海鲜屋之间的混合餐厅里吃饭。快速把这句话说十遍。我几乎说不出来。克兰西蟹肉专卖店。克兰西蟹肉专卖店。好吧，关于库珀餐厅还有这么一个小故事。好吧。布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳和我在2007年去过斯克兰顿的那家店。如果你上网访问库珀海鲜屋的网站，他们的相册板块里有我和布莱恩的一堆照片。我看到了。其中一张特别搞笑，我光着脚。
and standing on top of a table. Oh, I missed that one. It's a good one. I'll put it in our stories. Clearly Brian and I were there to have a good time. I'll put it in our stories. Clearly Brian and I were there to have a good time. And we did. We had a blast. Well, this scene originally started with Michael ordering for he and Holly. Yes, he was going to be fancy man on a date. He said this restaurant was business romantic. Here's what he ordered. We'll have the chowders to start, then the lobster
feast for two, and do you have a house red? And then he wants you to know, house makes a great red. Yes, I feel like, where did he come up with that? He heard that somewhere. Someone was like, the house wine is very good. The house makes a great red. And now he's like, he thinks the house is the winery. Yes. Well, Holly says she just wants a chef salad, no dressing. With an iced tea. Yeah, she's not going to have any house red. And then the waitress says to Michael, do you still want the two lobsters? And Michael says, yes, yes, I do.
Because now he's a little embarrassed. So later in the scene when you see Michael and he's got two lobsters and a big bowl of soup and a red wine, this is why. Yes, it's at 13 minutes 44 seconds. You'll see how he ordered double. Incidentally, on the Cooper's menu, there is a recurring Tuesday special called Twin Tales and a Cup of Soup. And it is two lobster tails and a bread bowl of soup. And I am dying to know if this Tuesday special predated this episode of The Office or if they created this as a special after Michael ordered two lobster tails in a bowl of soup. I don't know how to find out.
Well, we'll have to go. Anyone? Coopers? Anyone? Yeah. Well, here's the thing. We are going to Scranton. We are. I can't wait. Should we order two lobster tails and a bowl of soup? And the house red? Yes. We're going to do so much eating in Scranton. I know. The bulk of our trip there is just eating our way through Scranton. I know. Well, this lunch, it just is not going well. They cannot get on the same page about what to do with Meredith. No, they can't.
Michael was trying to just connect with Holly, get to know her. He asked her about where she grew up, Des Moines. We find out she's from Des Moines, Iowa. Right? Holly is being business. This is a business lunch. And she feels gross about Meredith. They have
this couplet of dialogue that really sums it up. Holly says, I'm saying that Meredith's behavior is unethical and a little icky and I don't think I want to work in an environment where that sort of conduct is tolerated. Michael says, well, you have to tolerate a lot when you're a part of a family. And Holly delivers such a low blow, if you know Michael, she says, it's not a family, it's a workplace. Oh my gosh, the look on his face. Like, how do they come back from this? Meanwhile, back at the office, Jim
is really trying to trap Dwight into wasting time. He's trying to get him to have personal conversations. He tries to explain an episode of Battlestar Galactica to Andy, purposely getting everything wrong and inserting all kinds of other characters. All kinds of other characters. He says it's like the crazy monsters and stuff. There's Klingons and Wookiees. He says there's a guy named Dumbledore. They're trying to get a ring back to Mordor. This is triggering every button in Dwight.
I loved Rain in the scene where he just was. And I also just loved the way John would hold up the stopwatch. Oh yeah, they were doing this beautiful comedic dance. It was so good. It was so good. We had a fan point out, Lindsay H said, I am so impressed with the camera focus when Jim is talking to Andy about Battlestar Galactica slash Star Wars slash Harry Potter slash Lord of the Rings
slash Star Wars. Anyway, she says, the camera focuses on Jim, then Dwight, and back and forth so quickly and flawlessly. She just wanted to give kudos to our camera operators. Yeah. Yeah, because, I mean, John and Rain are doing the stamps, but they're in it with the camera operator and that was flawless. I agree, Lindsay.
Me too. We also had a fan catch from Justin S. Jenna, I know you and Phyllis are both from St. Louis and I'm a big Cardinals fan myself and I couldn't help but notice that there is a free bird on Phyllis's desk over Dwight's shoulder. And I was just wondering, how did the free bird get there? Guys, I texted Phyllis about it. Yeah? We don't know.
She said, oh, maybe that was when David Friese and Matt Holliday came to visit. And I was like, no, they haven't come to visit yet. I'll tell you guys that story later. That was amazing. You guys were so excited. And I know they hadn't visited yet because Ellie was with us when they visited. So Phyllis and I went back and forth and she's like, I didn't bring it in.
She said, I don't know who put it there. I didn't put it there. Phyllis didn't put it there. We don't know who put it there. Well, Justin, I'm sorry. I'm going to try to get to the bottom of it, you know, answer pending. Yeah. Jim has a talking head that Dwight hasn't stopped working for a second. He even sneezed with his eyes open, which Jim was like, I didn't know that was possible. You guys, he peed in a soda bottle. He peed under his desk.
I mean, he is not going to waste any time. I had to know if you can sneeze with your eyes open. You can't. You can. What? Yeah. Mythbusters did a whole story on it. Mythbusters?
And I watched it late last night when I suddenly had to know. We both went on two random tangents. Just wait for mine. Is yours about the average amount of time someone has sex? Because I went on that tangent too. Yes! Yes! Oh my gosh!
Yes! Okay, because there's all of a sudden Dwight is like, not wasting time, not wasting time. And then he comes back and Jim is like, 19 minutes and 48 seconds. What were you up to? And Dwight is like, none of your business, basically. And then it cuts to Angela Martin buttoning her blouse. Did you read the research on Business Insider? I read several articles at like midnight last night.
Me too! On this subject. Our search history. Oh my God. To lead our search history. First of all, the one research I read about was fascinating because they gave 500 couples stopwatches. It is as awkward as it sounds.
They had to hit start and stop. I don't know how we talk about this, but maybe parents, if you're listening with your kids. Earmuffs for 30 seconds, earmuffs. Yeah. They had to record their sex time over a four-week period and they had to press start on the stopwatch at the moment of penetration. Oh, God. And they had to press stop at ejaculation.
We read the same article. Oh my God. You know what I found amazing is the range was from 33 seconds to 44 minutes. Yeah. That's a huge, huge variation. It is. And then what was really interesting to me
was I read this whole article by a sex therapist who after doing a bunch of research broke down the ideal amount of penetration time in a sex act. I mean, this is insane. I told Lee all last night, everything I'd read, he's like, how are you sharing this on Office Ladies? I was like, I don't know, but I found it so fascinating.
So what she found was that in surveying the person being penetrated, that their ideal amount of penetration time in sex was anywhere from 5 to 11 minutes. But all of sex, they all wanted more than just penetration. So she deemed that like the ideal amount of sex encompassing more than just that moment would be around 19 minutes and that it should consist of 10 minutes of foreplay and nine minutes of actual intercourse that she felt this was the bullseye after all of her research. Okay. Well, something I discovered in my research is that of these 500 couples surveyed, the average time was 5.4 minutes.
And this was true across continents. I mean, literally, it's a global thing. And this got me to thinking, 19 minutes and 48 seconds. I did the math. I think it took them six minutes to get down to the warehouse. Six minutes to walk down a set of stairs? Or take the elevator. It's not close. They minutes to walk down a set of stairs? Or take the elevator? It's
not close. They have to go in the elevator or stairs and they have to go down the corridor through the warehouse to that back room, open it up. All right, so six minutes to get there. They need six minutes back. That leaves them six minutes in the middle. Oh, I think they had six minutes to shag. I mean, I think what we've discovered in all our research is you can have a really satisfying shag in six minutes. By the way, this article went on to the evolution of sex. Why is there thrusting? It was fascinating.
I was fascinated. Oh, the things we have learned. And shared with you all, so you're welcome. Well, let's get back to this Michael Hawley story, okay? This whole lunch has really strained things between Michael and Hawley. When he gets back, he has a talking head where he says he won't even ride the elevator with her. And then he throws her leftovers in the trash.
Yeah. And then up in the kitchen, he's pouring himself some coffee. She puts her cup out. Not only does he not pour coffee in her cup, he takes the whole pot and walks out of the kitchen. She called Dunder Mifflin a workplace and it is his family. And you do not do that. You do not. If Holly wants to use the copier now, she's going to have to wait for Michael to copy a plaque off the wall first. Yeah. Well, Holly has a talking head.
Things are tense. People are suspicious of her. Her best friend in the office won't even speak to her. So now we have a little window into Holly. She really sees Michael as her best friend. Now Angela, in the script, there was a scene here where Michael calls Toby. Yes. For help with Holly.
Yes, it's in the deleted scenes. Oh, guys, it's so good because Toby basically says at the end of all of this, oh, well, Michael, I think Holly's doing the right thing. And in fact, now that you've told me, I'm obligated to report this Meredith incident to HR as well. Yeah. But that's how desperate Michael is, is he's going to call Toby, who I guess is still in a hospital in Costa Rica. And he's still not nice to him. He calls Toby for help, but he's still not nice.
This is not the last HR rep that's going to be involved. Kendall from Corporate has called and Holly's going to come in Michael's office and they're going to discuss it with Kendall. We had a fan question from Megan Q, who voices Kendall from Corporate HR? Kendall was played by John Hartman. Now, the role of Kendall was first mentioned in the episode, The Job, when David Wallace mentions his dislike for the HR rep, Kendall, during Jim's job interview in New York. Wow, that's a major callback.
I know, but we also brought him up again in weight loss, I guess. And here's the thing, Kendall is gonna come back two more times this season. He comes back in person in Stress Relief and Company Picnic. He's always played by John Hartman. You might recognize John, he had roles in Mad Men, Arrested Development, The Good Place, Blackish, Space Force,
and Monk. Ah, there it is. Of course. There it is. Well, you think Kendall is going to get Holly's back, right? And agree with her. But instead, he just shuts her down, says he doesn't really see this as a huge infraction. And what she needed to do was to get everyone through that binder.
That was her job. Yeah. We just needed you to get signatures. Are you able to get signatures or not? Because every other branch got signatures. And I think Michael feels badly for her in this moment. I feel badly for her. I do too. She's doing the right thing and corporate doesn't have her back. So Holly is just going to go out to the bullpen and say, hey guys, I have to finish this ethics training. She has to finish reading from the binder so she can say she did it.
No one is giving her any respect. Well, Michael's gonna step up. Yeah. Because he does feel bad for her. So he goes out there and he goes up, you don't get in there right now. He loses it. It's so funny. Everyone goes in, she reads from the binder and the look on Michael's face as she's like reading from the boring binder. He's in love again. Well, I don't think he ever fell out of love. They had their first spat. I guess they did. Yeah. Because Holly looks appreciative. They're both like, oh, okay, we're back. We're gonna get through this. Yeah. At the very end of this episode, we have a tag.
Everyone's in the break room. They're eating steak that was clearly provided by Meredith. We had a fan question from Kelly W. Okay, Kelly, what is it? During the last scene, when everyone's eating steak in the break room, what is everyone actually eating? Is it prop food or actually real expensive steak? And Savi A wants to know Angela, what were you eating since your character is a vegetarian? I was eating potatoes.
That's what it looked like to me. I was eating potatoes. That's something we thought about. One of the things that Peter and Vartan shared is that our prop food was amazingly good food. Oh yeah. That they didn't give us like kind of crappy food to eat in scenes. And Peter and Vartan would work with props, but I would have to think that Phil Shea and his team got us really good food from a restaurant. That was going to be my guess. Whenever I ate food in a scene, it was delicious.
Yeah. So it was probably some really good steak. What a day at work. Hey guys, come in and eat these steak and ribs for an hour. Angela, you can have these potatoes. Sorry, Ange. Well, there you have it. That's business ethics. Yeah. Thank you so much to Amy Ryan. And thank you to James O'Carrie for giving me the lowdown on Coopers.
And thank you to BJ Novak for pitching Peter and Vartan and Sergio and Alan to do the DVD commentary. That was just so wonderful. If you guys love the show, you'll love these commentaries. Well, I think on that note, I might go have a volcano. And I hope all of you guys have some hardcore love in your life. For approximately 19 minutes. Or an average of 6 minutes. That would be fine. See you next week.
Bye guys! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.